[Musique]
de son bateau
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission pas comme les
autres vous connaissez le principe tout
le monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
magnéto serge
akl mention à philippe corti
à
en
fait le même bruit que l'homme
[Applaudissements]
merci
seul le sait
allez salut
cortina
comment ça va vite ça y est eu
beaucoup beaucoup d'e-mails beaucoup du
mail pour thalia qui est revenu ce soir
beaucoup du mal de gens qui aimeraient
mieux vous connaître talia shire
10e
sa ministre
voici mimie mathy
[Applaudissements]
nous devons soir
soit ça
et oui la question de la fiche 69 les
rôles sont inversés c'est vous qui me
posais une question minimatic à ce qu'il
ya quelqu'un qui on a forcé à
interviewer et si ça se produisait
est-ce que tu le ferais bon on me force
pas parce qu'avec attaquant sait mais il
ya quelqu'un qui déteste et interviewé
ben c'est pas moi pour poser la question
non je pense qu'il ya des gens que
j'aime plus ou moins mais quand je les
aime moins ça se voit voilà quelqu'un
que j'aimerais pas du tout je prendrais
pas dans l'émission parce que avec
catherine on on s'arrange pour pas les
prendre quoi bien on va parler un peu de
[Applaudissements]
bien alors minima tient en fait votre
vrai prénom c'est michel bah oui c'est
pas original vous êtes né de lui juillet
57 à lyon exactement
je vous ai unis 20 minutes à pousser
votre premier cri oui c'est tout ce
temps là selon eux est foutu il avait
résisté j'ai résisté maman s'est dit si
celle-là survie enfin celle là
parce qu'ils en avaient pas acheté
plusieurs avancées
devraient commencer d'ici si elle survit
elle aura forcément un destin un peu un
peu hors normes c'était pas trop trompé
par et non pas du tout mais alors votre
père mais c'est quelqu'un qui s'était
fait tout seul à la force du poignet
enfin ils avaient des parents aussi mes
compères devant leur
but c'est quelqu'un qui avait commencé
comme un jeu pas très bas dans l'échelle
sociale et kenny chef du service
transport dans l'usiné basque dans la
famille quand on décide d'aller quelque
chose a commencé en bas je suis là mais
moi j'ai préféré rester parce qu'il ya
des avantages
[Applaudissements]
alors de fleurs
un autre foyer alors vous allez les
grands-parents assez rigolo vos grands
parents paternels il avait un stand de
confiserie vendait des berlingots dans
les foires vous alliez avec eux ça nous
faire du bien c'est avec joie la marche
en avait des tours de manège gratuits on
était en vie par tous les enfants les
enfants du quartier à pied les grands
parents maternels tp marcel marcel était
un cro bat plus ils étaient acrobates et
il a affiné imprésario de mick micheyl
de mick micheyl il a refusé des
compagnons de la chanson c'est qu'ils y
croyaient pas s'il avait jacques elian
et mick micheyl oui il a refusé les
compagnons de la chanson musique bah oui
ça se voit si on dit la vérité
alors effectivement dans votre plus
jeune âge personne s'aperçoit du
handicap au départ dont dans la famille
on nettoie les pieds après votre grand
mère paternelle mabille est un jour elle
s'inquiète du manque de souplesse de vos
pieds vous amène chez un pédiatre et là
le pédiatre lui dit oui alors vous
souffrez d'un conte la vie c'est quoi
c'est exactement ben c'est c'est le fait
de comment dire d'être très bien
proportionné au niveau du buste d'avoir
tout ce qu'il faut là où il faut mais
d'avoir des bras et des jambes un peu
plus autour de la moyenne quoi voilà et
là il vos parents vous emmène chez un
autre médecin il a fait flipper tout le
monde parce que le médecin il a dit
forêts j'avais plus de 80 cm normalement
je devais pas dépasser 80 cm et vit à
une solution celle opérée si elle reste
trois ans sur un lit avec des attelles
des machins lui écarte end mes parents
dit au revoir monsieur merci a bientot
enfin à jamais plus tôt et puis ils ont
décidé que je grandirai pas
normalement parce qu'en 32 finalement
vous êtes jamais qu'aqua 20 cm de lister
lors d'une certaine façon oui puis j'ai
pigé d'autres avantages oui bah oui
alors finalement vous continuer à
grandir la deuxième année vous prenez 10
cm est alors à l'école bizarrement c'est
à dire que vous êtes très turbulent de
chef de bande à l'école tête à 100
content quand on est différent on n'a
pas le choix soit on se cache dans un
coin où on se met avec des gens comme
nous reçoit en échec de bande moi j'ai
choisi d'être chef de bande quoi j'étais
tombé dans une piscine d'optimisme quand
j'étais petit je pense que mes parents
m'ont appris ça aussi et j'ai décidé de
et vous riposté tout de suite en temps
vous tire la langue vous retournez vous
tirer aussi la langue
on a tous un défaut donc si on me
reprochait ma taille moi je trouvais
toujours quelque chose à reprocher à
ceux qui nous reprochaient on devenait
les meilleurs amis du monde après petit
mais grande gueule ah bah oui je peux
pas te laisser aux autres alors en fait
vous prenez conscience de votre taille
non pas dans la famille parce qu'ils
étaient plutôt cool avec vous avec un
voisin qui s'appelait jean paul et qui
vous a dit un jour c'est vraiment si si
mais il vous a dit un jour d'abord tu es
humaine c'est la première fois vous
entendez le mot comme ça s'est bien
passé a choqué 1 alors la mère de jean
paul est venu voir votre mère en disant
écoutez mon fils a fait une connerie
épouvantable mais je suis désolé
reconnaître que je avait déchiré son 15e
un bouquin à lui qu'il est mais qui
voulaient pas me prêter je vais jamais
provoqué ouais je réponds que non mais
il m'a dit ça et j'ai dû le répondre
quelque chose je vous ai pas traumatiser
en tous les cas banon visiter un sens je
peux pas faire autrement je suis comme
ça donc quand on se regarde dans une
glace et comme je suis une fille je me
regarde relativement souvent dans une
glace j'ai bon ben c'est comme ça c'est
comme ça alors votre première vocation
c'était de devenir chez la wii a évolué
heureusement je sais
non mais c'est vrai que je voulais faire
chez eux d'ailleurs c'est là que
rapid ap ringo tu regardes pas noir
je voulais faire chanteuse ouais ouais
alors là où c'est devenu un petit peu
plus compliqué effectivement pour vous
c'est l'adolescence évidemment parce que
bon c'est difficile à nager moiron les
pelles les autres
c'est à dire que c'est c'est un âge non
mais c'est vrai c'est un âge où les
garçons ont du mal à assumer leurs actes
donc voilà
quelqu'un qui est différent mais vous
avez vous avez pleuré vous avez souffert
mais finalement vous n'avez jamais été
quand même complètement non bâti je me
suis toujours entouré de plein de gens
qui est positif qui me qu'était j'ai un
cocon autour de moi toujours c'est
peut-être le cocon qu'on se fait soi
même mais si tu je me suis toujours
préservé quoi donc ils passent bien sûr
j'ai chialé bien sûr je me suis dit
tiens je vais encore j'aurais bien roulé
a pas de temps parce que les mecs qui me
disait ans mais non faut pas ça
gâcherait notre amitié oui bah y'en a
qui vous a dit ça vient d'un caniche
peur de te faire du mal agi après les
sorties que votre copine vous l'avez
détesté par un videur entend donc
l'amitié gens n'avaient rien de notable
t'aimer mais bon c'est bien le penser
mais c'est vrai que après je me suis
rattrapé d'une certaine façon ça vous a
renforcé cette histoire et ça vous a
obligé est drôle en disant ben voilà
pourquoi on s'intéresse à moi soit faut
que je sois prêt se faire remarquer
d'une façon ou d'une autre moi j'ai
essayé de j'essayais pas faire honte aux
gens que j'aime et qui m'aiment et alors
quand vous rencontrez votre premier
amour à l'âge de 20 ans là c'est la
totale quoi sert vous allez vous
évidemment un petit peu de temps à
rattraper d'une certaine façon oh là là
j'ai donné la ct premier baiser prenez
des avec la langue première tout en même
temps oui d'un seul coup comme ça a batu
savait tout faire j'avais vu des films
et on va expliquer cette affaire la
totale c'est le rugbyman
les
quotas sont jamais mêlés petit groupe
très costaud rugbyman marié avec des
enfants dix ans de plus que vous un ben
ouais ouais vous êtes dit ça y est quoi
non je me suis dit ça y est c'est fait
ça y est je suis comme tout le monde
copie de la
wii est un cas très bien
alors la même époque vous prenez
conscience que vous avez envie de faire
faire des choses et vous écrivez une
lettre aux choristes en amical à aider
qui la publie il y avait une phrase qui
est très très jolie je vais la cité vous
disiez la petitesse n'est que quelque
chose de morale qui n'a rien à voir avec
le physique mais je pense moi j'ai
rencontré plein de gens beaucoup plus
petit que moi
voilà alors après évidemment bon voulu
être journaliste dont vous faites un
deug épine licence et vous raté la
licence pour trois quart de point oui
mais je savais très bien que je voulais
pas faire ça je savais très bien que je
voulais faire le je voulais rentrer dans
le métier donc j'ai pas repasser j'ai
pas passer le rattrapage et là vous
partez vous alliez à l'époque en
vacances dans les landes oui hélas vous
montiez avec votre copain à vous montrer
dé monter des spectacles j'étais
animatrice comme ben oui
et je remontais j'étais animatrice l'été
pour me faire un peu d'argent de poche
les études et ont monté des spectacles
et puis et puis c'était un avant goût de
la scène à un niveau amateur bien sûr
mais c'était un avant goût du public
puisqu'on y en avait des salles de mille
classes j'ai pas toujours eu ça au début
ou décidé de faire ça à plein temps et
première saison vous allez aux ménuires
vous c'est aux menuires et là vous
entendez parler du projet de michel
fugain fameux l'atelier doit remonter
aux studios de la victorine à nice et
vous le rejoignez j'allais passer
l'audition les ans et moi voilà je sais
rien faire mais j'arrivais y avait plein
de danseuses de nanas qui avait déjà
fait deux trois ans de danse qu'ils
faisaient
moi je disais mais j'ai rien fait je
vais je vais lui réciter un poème de
prévert je vais avoir l'air tartignole
mais j'ai récité mon poème de prévert et
puis m'a gardé et puis et puis j'ai fait
deux ans à l'atelier fuyant il lui a dit
un truc génial vous ai dit c'est pas toi
qui dansent pas comme les autres ce sont
les autres qui il a pris le relais de
mes parents en fait michel lima il m'a
aidé à me dire bon ben ok t'es
différentes mais n'en fait pas n'en fait
surtout pas une faiblesse faisant une
force ouais alors ensuite bon ben voila
a pris la carrière qu'on connaît quel
point virgule il ya bouvard le petit
théâtre de bouvard magnifique expérience
simple un superbe
bien de ta taille déjà c'est
la première fois qu'il se penchait pour
embrasser quelqu'un
voilà il ya tous les boulevards il ya
bien les filles avec michèle bernier et
isabelle de botton 1 1 et puis un jour
bas ça s'arrête avec les filles c'est
comme toutes les troupes on reste très
amis mais on a des envies différentes et
puis il ya des opportunités
à l'époque de la séparation avec les
figer j'avais on m'avait proposé
d'écrire un téléfilm j'ai écrit la
nounou et puis après ça s'est enchaîné
puis ou la série puis a eu un autre
spectacle puis et puis on se revoit
toujours avec plaisir avec les filles
peut-être qu'on refera des choses
ensemble isabelle vient d'écrire un des
épisodes de l'ange-gardien j'ai tourné
puisqu'elle écrit beaucoup et divinement
bien et je sais la vie quoi c'est ça
n'empêche pas de continuer à se voir de
continuer à s'apprécier mais on a
chacune des voies différentes à suivre
alors dites moi comment ça se passe la
vie quotidienne pour vous c'est passé
pas embêtant parce que les distributeurs
automatiques de billets soient trop
grands ou non mais je m'arrange vous
arranger faire payer au noir
non je rigole rigole je rigole c'est une
blague sur le contrôleur des impôts non
mais non mais ça se passe très bien je
peux te dire j'ai pas de ya plein de
distributeurs qui sera matin ici en 1 4
euro je demande à quelqu'un de m'aider
dans la vie que le conduire une bagnole
par exemple ce n'est pas un problème
mais elles sont allées à ménager ma
bagnole un 4/4 parce que je déteste les
petites voitures donc là sont les hôtes
de cette mesure
non mais j'ai eu il ya aucun souci tout
si j'atteins pas quelque chose je
demande c'est que c'est pas un problème
oui avec les mecs comment ça se passe je
vous dit des fois j'ai des problèmes de
confiance en moi dans l'est dans les
moments intimes politique si je mesure 1
m 32 habiller une fois nous je me vois
toujours à mettre trente deux d'entre
eux présentent quand je discute avec
toutes mes copines ça me rassure parce
qu'elles ont toutes les mêmes problèmes
quoi avec les mecs on n'est jamais sûr
de soi et les murs sont jamais sûrs
d'eux avec sociaux à part quelques
crétins qui croient qu'ils sont parfaits
mais vous n'êtes pas
mais non patrick est parfait dans ce
niveau-là il doute de lui aussi est mais
je crois qu'il faut non je crois qu'une
fois allongé tout va bien
[Musique]
vous aimeriez faire des enfants c'est un
peu tard maintenant parce que si ceux
qui savent calculer et qui regardent
cette émission j'ai 40 ans voire 44 ans
et une femme de 62 ans qui vient de
faire un enfant oui mais alors là faut
l'abattre l1 fois bon bah non méchant je
suis entouré d'enfants puisque j'ai huit
g8 filleul jeu des nouveaux et nièces en
fait j'ai que les avantages et j'ai pas
les inconvénients donc c'est fabuleux
mais s'il a entouré d'enfants dans la
ville a maintenant je vais vous les plus
offerts là bas à moins que ce soir on
décide avec patrick d'en faire un faux
faire très vite
alors vous dit un truc extraordinaire je
crois que si on me demande est
maintenant de finalement si on me
demandait de changer de taille et
reprend d'une taille normale je voudrais
pas ça me ferait drôle ouais ça me
ferait drôle parce que je me suis
habitué ça non je crois que toute façon
en plus su assez je suis assez réaliste
donc lui à partir non chez vous savez
que c'est pas possible non c'est vrai
que je me sens bien dans mes baskets
même si j'aimais coup de mou comme tout
le monde mais j'en ai pas plus que mes
copines et copains et l'abandon non j'ai
pas envie de changer
[Musique]
attention on ne bouge pas pendant le
tignard
[Applaudissements]
bacchus reprennent du poil de la bête
rien qui va heureusement ils sont en
vacances après avoir en septembre on va
organiser le mouvement le mouvement
belle piste il ya des basques à 56 cosec
à san francisco il ya un mouvement
bassiste et un bar spelle baffie barre
les universités d'été
je ne me refuse bien ce que vous
préférez en vous
donc on est têtu
ce que vous détestez en vous donc on est
têtu ce que vous préférez dans le cinéma
c'est qu'on a plus de temps que sur les
téléfilms et
on peut se permettre plus de choses
parce que s'il n'y a pas de ya pas de
contraintes de la chaîne car il faut
attendre l'image attention à tout on
peut plus délirer ce que vous ne m'aimez
pas dans le cinéma
et film chiant
ce qui vous fait le plus rire dans la
vie
[Musique]
l'autodérision le moi rire
la connerie humaine
l'intolérance leur a dit ni sme
pour la médecine la tolérance
le plus belle histoire d'amour la
prochaine le plus moche
ce que vous avez de plus sexy en vous
laisse un
et deux mois sexy
les jambes ce que vous préférez dans le
sexe
l'homme si vous détestez dans le sexe
que je déteste dans le sexe c'est quand
on quand on dit c'est fini ouais y'a des
gens qui lisent raillait
ce jeu est fun pendant que l'homme
marchait sur la lune
bennati ça sort
juillet les messieurs
magnéto serre je demande a mis sur le
coca qui dirait je pense d'eux une prime
de risque je ne peux pas faire cette
émission je ne peux plus faire cette
émission que tu sais comment les bonnes
remettre un cadeau
c'est bon
sa branche
arrête c'est bon salut ma réponse je
suis excité pour autant
et
moi
trop
ils ont dû y faire
la famille
je vais vous poser une devinette leur
wii et vous parlez moi
le pays
qui est le mien
qui sert votre avis un cake la
kim
yang gon
[Musique]
salut bonsoir
jean tour dans l'âme et la minceur
[Applaudissements]
jean claude van damme alors jean-claude
vous parlez français sans problème oui
oui ça va non parce que vous dites j'ai
presque peur de parler français oui
c'est vrai parce que quand je fais des
heures parce que j'habite en amérique je
parle souvent en anglais un stop du
matin au soir alors quand je viens ici
je fais de mon mieux mais parfois je
fais des petites heures de français
bêtisier d'ailleurs alors il ya des gens
comme ça qui s'occupe de ça pour bien
des cas ils sont payés pour ça ils sont
prêts pour ça ils sont c'est super ils
sont payés pour ça voilà je vais
t'exploser
je
qu'il était dans le business des armes
avant d'aller weapon la
dynamique
bien alors jean-claude on arrive à la
question de la fiche numéro 69
donc ses rôles sont inversés c'est vous
c'est vous jean claude van damme qui
devait me posais une question posée moi
la question que vous voulez à
l'app store mac et wallace et un
kibboutz aussi que c'était ma question
bien
[Applaudissements]
gvt
alors jean claude van damme vous êtes né
le plat pays
[Musique]
notre idole oui j'étais en 1960 donc en
belgique votre terre était libraire et
puis ensuite fleuriste et c'est vrai que
votre mère vendait des soutiens-gorge
way est très longtemps ouais dans une
rue de flandre dans le quartier des
marolles carte est très pauvre
soutien d'enfants assez chétif chétif
vaste algique pas du tout le genre de
van damme qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
anxieux anxieux sent toujours plongé
dans les livres et quand je veux non à
l'amérique parce que bon j'ai fait du
sport mon père m'a pris à l' âge très
jeune à l'âge de 11 ans elle va faire du
karaté vu que j'étais pas tellement fort
physiquement et j'ai pu me développer
mentalement et physiquement grâce au
karaté merci ça c'est votre père quand
vous allez 12 ans vous emmène saint
claude goetz entraîneur de karaté et là
au début vous êtes un peu raide un peu
craintif mais vous avez nouveau staff et
une volonté d'en faire moi j'ai
progressé je suis très déterminé vous
souffrez vous abandonner mais toujours
vous revenez comme ça mais tu as peu
violent gare de la faire de la
musculation et la sortie vous êtes un
champion de karaté à l'âge de l'âge de
17 ans précise le champion d'europe en
79 et champion du monde à waco en
floride et visait le virus de l'amérique
à ce moment là s'ils voulaient
absolument aller habiter aux états unis
depuis longtemps
depuis l'âge de chez pas l'âge de 16 17
ans je rêvais d'amérique pourquoi je ne
sais pas c'est à dire que je crois que
dans la vie on a tous une mission à
faire et c'était pour moi j'avais
j'avais cette histoire l'amérique dans
la peau depuis le matin jusqu'au soir le
film est toujours rêver d'amérique je
suis parti en amérique j'ai tenté ma
chance ouais là en 83 vous commencez à
faire du cinéma vous jouer un petit rôle
dans rue barbare de gilles béhat j'étais
rentré du film mais avant pourquoi ben
j'étais arrivé un jour trop tard ouais
il m'avait dit je dis souvent je sais
pas quoi je suis avec le train et
répandre l'époque j'étais sur le set à
3-2 matin j'attends des grains contout
seul qui ait un problème je sais je suis
parti à pompe téléphone made un espèce
de conte et belges et tout cela il
malick suffrages à mehdi chine et matin
raté de l'emballage et qu'est ce que
j'ai fait en france j'ai brûlé ma carte
1 a jamais eu peur après vous repartez
donc à los angeles alors vous parlez pas
anglais vous avez pas de carte de
travail et puis à des milliers
d'américains qui vont à l'assaut de
jeunesse pour faire fortune dans cinéma
qui ont le même rêve que vous les
millions dont il vous faudra huit ans
pour vous en sortir leur vous êtes
vendeur de pizza videur de boîte de nuit
chauffeur de limousine de pizzas
faites tous les boulots quoi ouais le
pire boulot vous ayez fait c'est quoi
attendre ouais
le chauffeur de limousine le travail
c'est super quand admission dans la vie
et qu'on veut faire quelque chose et on
pense charia on pense à aftout be je
dois être un acteur on peut les mettre
bits ou rave je suis un acteur je suis
allé je travaille peu d'acteurs et le
haf c'est déjà parti c'est à bruxelles
alors quand gm en amérique j'étais
acteur même les pizzas que je lai le
livret où j'allais
des vitesses que tu veux j'avais j'étais
acteur dans ma tête j'ai réussi un et
alors qu'on pense comme ça la vie c'est
pour tout le monde pour tous les
français pour tous les belges pour le
monde entier quand vraiment en confiance
ou un mystère tout d'olive de believe
quand même confiance à la confiance on
devient confiant sur cette mission il ya
beaucoup de gens qui disent un jour
peut-être que je sache à sa fin qui se
passe ouais faut être persévérant ton
prudent
avec la jeune fille
alors on fait plein de boulot donc vous
êtes chauffeur de limousine et vous
dites que vous avez beaucoup appris en
conduisant des petits cons plein de
pognon qu'ils se foutaient en l'air avec
de la drogue ah ça vous a pas empêché de
faire pareil après maintenant
et pendant des années donc vous essayer
de rencontrer des producteurs des
acteurs faisaient tout genre de mec un
peu collant faut dire la vérité c'est
que vous êtes vous êtes on est des mecs
sur les parkings les acteurs les
producteurs mais c'était avant la drogue
un oui bien sûr important
mais c'est bien plus tard qu'en fait les
quand on fait de la drogue on sait plus
que m quelle voiture c'est et qu'est la
grêle mais qu'on a parlé ya un truc qui
se passe là donc vous allez mettre des
tracts sous les pare brise et que votre
nom votre numéro de téléphone et où vous
êtes le genre de mec un peu collant
quand même pas qu'al en insistant à et
très insistants un collant si on a le
sticker la jemaye vm cash l'épaule il
parce qu'avec vous l'enlever de la
déchirer non j'avais à classe quoi vous
faites aussi le siège des dents dans le
wall marin vous faites aussi le siège
des domiciles des stars donc stallone
schwarzenegger chuck norris et un jour
vous décidé de tenter le tout pour le
tout il ya un producteur qui s'appelle
menahem golan et vous lui faites à la
sortie d'un restaurant un maroilles chi
c'est quoi un match y relier montreux
c'est vrai parce que je n'ai pas peur je
vais faire une rame enrichi aux fleurs
ou sa caméra l'a bien ici j'ai tout à
l'heure au théâtre on n'est pas
je le touche ou pas
la peur battant c'est un roc sur un bas
mais alors j'ai pas comme ça j'avais mal
à rennes
voila
je m'en vais
t'apprendre un truc c'est un peu
technique mais je serais je vais faire
casser l'arête du nez
moi je connais les garçons comme elsa
distance distance il doit la vox hd à la
santé
l'un d'eux c'était à la sortie d'un
restaurant donc que la victime était la
rigolade donc été un grand producteur de
cinéma américain à l'époque à l'époque
bien entendu et le lendemain ils vous
invitent au bureau il vous fait attendre
pendant six heures et au bout de six
heures vous rentrez dans son bureau et
vous lui faites un grand écart entre
deux chaises
ayé c'était plus que ça d'abord j'ai
j'essaie de me vendre vite un vendeur
maintenant rim est un vendeur sait pas
c'est pas un producteur à la halle à
jerry bruckheimer km 110 milliards pour
un film lui fais des films pour 4 5
millions $ et les vents pour rossi 7,17
à mandeure ok alors j'entendais les
vendeurs parler de gauche à droite
georges à me vendre excusez moi alors je
suis rentré dans l'office et je le porte
clés ouais ouais ouais super comme mec
est très intelligent et toi aussi
d'ailleurs et alors quand je rentre
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors qu'est ce
qui se passe j'ai parlé je pas bla bla
bla bla bla j'ai fait ceci et puis je
commence à broadway
j'écoutais les mecs c'est un suicide
j'en peux plus dire c'est que je suis là
j'en peux plus je n'en peux plus je n'en
peux plus j'ai été dans son temps c'est
très très bien la vérité parce qu'il ya
rien de venir avis que dire la vérité
quand tu dis est la vérité jamais jamais
un problème n'a pas de discussions à
tous ces natures et alors si passé il a
craqué pour moi a dit ok qui fait beau
le sport telles cartes vertes j'ai dit
ouais bien sûr je n'avais pas alors je
dis franchement d'avocats droite est
elle heureusement que le film s'est fait
en com - là j'étais sauvée à cause de
l'immigration devient son assistante qui
s'appelait kelly apporte mois d'août ce
porte qui était le synopsis du film et
vous a dit you want to be used à alma
qstar ouais ça veut dire quoi
savoir ce qu'il faut savoir quand même
jean-claude c'est quand le film est
terminé menahem golan il ne trouve pas
terrible directement le vendre en vidéo
en cassette sans passer par les le
professeur de cinéma le problème c'est
important qu'on producteurs et le
découpage d'un fils ouais alors quand on
fait un coup de pied comme je t'ai fait
là et qu on le découpe au milieu et on
va sur un closet des chinois qui fait
quoi et puis qu'on revient sur moi et on
va nous coûter sachions et
j'espère le jour à très grand peuple
mais seulement ce qui se passe
et ils ont découpé
s'est passé tu devrais découper les
pieds j'avais découpé le film soir à ma
manière à moi le mieux que j'avais voilà
ce que je cherche des acheteurs partie
au moulin
nerveux comme découpage
vous allez vous moi la paix retourne en
belgique qui vous aidera non pas comme
ça je n'étais pas content on m'a dit tu
seras domaine star est adapté de là
alors après le film sorti six sept mois
après et grâce à la france la france
grâce à monsieur samuel hadida mon pote
sommes allés
distribuer beau sport en france a fait
un malheur voilà et donc après on va
appeler aux états unis jean claude van
damme de me seul from brussels ce qui
veut dire les muscles de bruxelles c'est
moi qui joue les mousses annoncé voilà
j'ai mais voilà j'ai pensé je vais faire
un seul ce monsieur
ça va bien tous les goûts
en anglais c'est ma chance ce qui est
bien que le service public on apprend le
projet vise maintenant je me sens déjà
beaucoup mieux le français va déjà mieux
non oui beaucoup mieux savary devant et
tout à l'heure jojo attention vous
enchaînez avec une série de succès
énorme succès pour pouvoir pour
l'investissement ouais super parce que
je peux regarder tous les étudiants dans
les yeux je suis seul acteur au monde et
je le dis encore maintenant chaque
producteur je peux et j'ai jamais perdre
et un français au cannes le film et non
ils peuvent dire ce qu'ils veulent il ya
aucun de mes films qu'ils apprenaient à
francs au calme et filme pas à santés
misant tout c'était de l'argent pour les
studios
même légionnaires mal et génère et là
ils étaient pris en vidéo en france et
les gens l'adorent m cinéma ouais c'est
différent et blanc qui bloque qui bloque
les rôles c'est comme réplique en
répliquant c'est pas un film de karaté 1
ça va être un beau y aura de l'action
d'accord mais c'est un film c'est
dramatique ce c'est autre chose mais les
gens ils ont une image james bond ça a
pris sean connery 20 ans pour changer
james bond du bitkom de 5,6
alors les gens quand ils ont une image
fixe et sur quelqu'un il reste sur la
bible ou le coran oui comme les
religions dont on va pas en parler mais
je veux dire que qu' il faut il faut un
peu avec les images
c'est normal
non mais j'ai l'impression aujourd'hui
il fait dans la vie il faut être là et
j'ai l'impression aujourd'hui que passer
pour un héros ça ne fasse une plume non
ses impressions vous avez - vous êtes
moins là dedans la route maintenant je
suis né j'ai l'impression immédiate est
que j'ai ainsi parce qu'on m'a vite je
suis bien j'aime bien mon public
français ce qu'ils m'ont fait
j'aurai la chance
mais c'est pas
les studios et alors il ya une histoire
qui se passe dans le monde du cinéma ce
qu'est ce que c'est super quand tu fais
un film et tu réussis les nouveaux
majeurs studio là le manque va
distribuer demand je le dis ce n'est du
coup c'est nouveau le mec est bien
l'épicière y aller
mais ce jeu m'intéresse pas
à l'âge de 42 ans là j'ai maintenant le
business fait autre chose un pour
l'instant alors il ya aussi des
problèmes j'ai eu des problèmes les
problèmes c'est bien non bon il ya eu la
coke un peu quoi lalala coûté la
coquette
et l'ourthe et de la coque la coff la
cour la coque il n'y a pas plus merdique
je l'aï jamais d'en prendre ok ça arrête
la tête [__] tout en l'air je ne sais
pas ce qu'on dira que c'est parce qu'on
rendait dingue alors on est très
d'accord la coke faut pas toucher c'est
de la merde j'ai essayé moi de l'abattre
on peut pas l'abattre alors elle devient
quand la connais elle devient un
compagnon qu'on touche pas allergique à
la co c'est très simple et c'est pour ça
que j'ai parlé maintenant je suis en
forme j'ai peur de personne qui fera les
yeux tu pas de coke toi bon je pars un
peu 8 c'est pas un problème rapide
jamais frappé pourquoi je mange des
légumes est en pleine forme
tu as raison tu as raison
lara roxx apparus les neurones
m'accapare s'ils savent six ans ils
peuvent envoyer de f fifteen à nos
copains ici à la ba et met toi mais ils
vont prendre un mec comme moi et vous
m'accusez parce qu'ils ont dans un petit
poisson comme ça qu'on lui comme ronan
alors entre tom robert downey junior ils
doivent prendre les gens comme ça les
secoue un peu pour les commercial ça
serait bien dans les journaux parce qu'à
la moitié de l'amérique et ses les
banques et tous ont fait de co
investissement c'est quoi mène tout le
ponot pas révèle sybille under mot chez
vous chez nous mais qui a vendu les
abris anti atomiques en irak qui j'ai
pas mon choix
le
monde
change élections un bien il faut montrer
la violence non à ce que parce qu'on
fait partie d'un monde de violence et on
peut pas dire aux enfants quand ils vont
dans la rue on veut on peut dire sans
s'engager sur la rue ça va être
disneyland tout aimé vous adorez non il
faut dire à l'enfant cas de la mer dans
la rue il ya de la coquille à ceux ci à
cela il ya beaucoup de danger cela
j'avais cassé le truc
alors on est d'accord alors non le vrai
problème c'est surtout que les bons
scripts ils vont plutôt chez tom cruise
et pourtant on vous dit je suis prêt à
tourner gratuitement avec un réalisateur
que j'admirais certains certainement pas
le même métier bien sûr ouais vite
maintenant attention ça a changé
j'aimerais faire un film
j'aimerais faire un film sur la vie de
jacques brel web s assèche je suis trop
jeune et trop
trop trop barak et voilà c'est un nom si
jamais je tombe malade s'est passé votre
projetons pas de problème de carrière
aujourd'hui c'est pas ça finalement
c'est je les envie de faire des films de
meilleure qualité avec des meilleurs
réalisateurs
non non j'aime bien m'occuper de mes
propres productions est ce que quand on
fait ou vous même et de l'amour qui se
donne dans le film dans le script dans
la production dans dans le jeu d'acteur
est juste un garçon aussi j'ai un
chat garçon que si je fais je travaille
pas tous les jours mais quinze heures
par jour je m'emmerde et quand je
m'emmerde fait des conneries mais voila
voila tu as beaucoup d'énergie en tout
et vous êtes maintenant le problème
laurent il ya un autre problème c'est
que jean claude et anxieux jean-claude
dit je n'irai pas à 60 ans vous a une
prémonition vous dites quelque 45 ans
vous êtes mort c'est possible parce que
je travaille très dur je travaille très
très dur moi je respecte la gamme comme
johnny parce que johnny hallyday il faut
une santé d'enseignement dans le show
business johnny c'est pas la fonction
non plus on le sait tous mais grâce à
dieu il a une santé superbe alors il ya
des acteurs qui ont une santé et à
d'autres camions moins bonne santé et si
si grâce à dieu si j'ai une bonne santé
je peux aller très très loin mais je
travaille très très dur et ça paye après
les artères paye les avions et retour
les bazars et céladon 40
si on fait quoi s'il vous reste trois
ans ah ouais c'est pas 6 3 en 1 1 sa
habitat les femmes ça vous fatiguent pas
un peu à
mais pour l'instant j'ai tellement juste
sur une histoire ce que je vais faire je
vais essayer de rentrer sur le monde
médiatique dans le net on va annoncer un
film dans le net de chaque pays vit on
ira sur le web et puis on fait avec des
antennes et tient-il opaque bell howell
le wild and in a wide band
hockey
son chapeau alors on va laisser et la
deutsche bahn on pourra toucher que sur
50 millions de view ouais ouais ça ça
c'est quelque chose de bien pour un film
de qualité avec les gens monde entier
les gens qui n'ont pas d'argent qu'ils
appuient sur le bouton ils doivent pas
attendre 40 heures pour le download
hockey parce que c'est fait avec web on
va distribuer les films avec le
téléphone sera âpre combat le match
tombe blanche sauvegarde ou date hockey
du coin loquace mais quand on attend pas
je peux pas attendre le satellite ouais
ils dépensent trop d'argent ça coûte des
millions de dollars alors on a trouvé un
système grâce au net c'est un moyen de
faire du pognon sa traduction
j'ai tellement le constat s'écrit r us
inc ah non bien
[Rires]
jean claude van damme aujourd'hui vous
avez assez d'argent pour vous arrêter de
bosser nom
assez pour moi mais pas assez pour les
autres parce que dans la vie vous
partagez ouais opus condom puisqu'on
reçoit et attention
qu'on donne quand donne sans recevoir
mais parce que quand on construit des
entités entity j'utilise entité
l'identité des gros radis t il faut il
faut gic a demandé en vain j'ai fait ma
vie j'ai roulé ma bosse j'ai fait la
cokerie des gens disent que j'ai fait 4
5 6 7 bis je sais pas quoi on est là on
a tout fait ok alors tous alors après on
fait un point sur la vie alors combien
de temps il reste à vivre 1 45 67 ans
chez pac en même temps il faut faire
quelque chose de bien la vie là j'ai des
fans qui m'aiment bien il ya des qui
m'aiment pas alors
il reste peu de temps à faire ça tu es
10 à 15 puisque de 40 à 50 ans on a
recensé après on devient un peu
fatigué mais c'est peut-être pour moi
lorsqu'il se passe ce qu'il faut faire
même à l'enjeu je peux je m'allongeais
20 minutes dans ma loge qui arrive avec
geneviève je suis un peu fatigué avec
j'aime bien mais j'ai mal soupire un peu
jeune j'aime bien
laisse nous laisse nous jamais eu un bon
jour car si tu as tu arrives with it
avec la nourrice la violence
alors dire vous avez tous avec les
femmes là alors j'ai ma femme je jette
remarier oui c'est incroyable s'être
marié avec gladys qui était votre
troisième femme mais être marié avec
elle qu'est ce qu'elle a de plus que les
autres parce que c'est un grand
séducteur quand même que c'est ce
qu'elle a fait récupérer non j'allais
sincère une mère de famille elle et
elle est parfaite elle est parfaite elle
elle dit du mal sur personne elle fait
du mal à personne
elle prend votre enfant par exemple en
vacances elle va traiter ton fils de
tout à fait aussi bien que mon fils et
ma fille elle m'a été envoyé par une
force de la nature qui s'appelle pour
certaines personnes dieu allah boudache
et pas comme on l'appelle est cette
femme s'occupe de moi et depuis qu'elle
redevenu dans ma vie ben jusqu'à sa
barre
bien jean claude van damme on va faire
une une interview psy vous savez qu'on
ne la bouge pas pendant les ting on ne
bouge pas pendant le bouge pas pendant
le jingle
il vous avez bougé je sais on peut
rallumer n'ont
pas bougé un peu mal
c'est pas gentil j'aime bien invité
jean-claude à côté de vous voir et et
voulait
aller alors on ne bouge pas besoin de
l'attention du on ne bouge pas pendant
qu'on ne bouge pas pendant le single on
ne bouge pas pendant le single
vient
alors est ce que vous êtes
jean claude van damme est ce que vous
êtes mito mitonnant je vous êtes mégalo
mais faut une tête gonflée pour avoir
pour booster son ego parce que ce fait
part de notre dans la nature humaine si
on n'est pas qu'on est bien dans la vie
si on dit qu'on est petit qu'est-ce
qu'on ait envie on va rester petit je
suis grand je suis forgé beau chez
madame
miss france dans l'ailé droite souple
parce que sommes allés ce que vous y
êtes est ce que vous êtes marbella est
ce que vous êtes parano par un an
absolument que tu prend là un d'accord
ok est ce que vous êtes cyclo
cyclone on s'est tous dit mic
cyclothymique ça a à voir avec la
musique l'air
d'être un jour comme si un jour comme ça
voilà un jour femmes et enfants non un
jour un punch gendarmes est ce que vous
êtes cyclo
pour lui on a tous deux abandonne mais
il faut pas faire attention à ces choses
là parce que si on fait attention à ces
mots on devient esclave des mots on
devient esclave de médicaments alors
tous ces gros ce groupe va racheter qui
font du fonds d'aidé under donc on est
tous normal on allait jouer les durs ou
ses hauts et bas
ya le soleil à la pluie à l'oreille des
journées de mauvaise humeur on et parlez
parlez vous êtes maso à on aime tous
avoir mal est ce que vous êtes sado non
sado-maso cyclo mcclure
est ce que vous êtes trio
trio c'est quoi ça 3
dans mon business on a trouvé l'amour un
nom en amour mais c'est comme l'amour
d'accord parce qu'être avoir des
partenaires c'est être amoureux des
vrais partenaires dans le business des
mecs qui se tiennent back to back pain
parce que moi j'ai connu ça quand j'ai
fait un coq suis tombé dans la merde
tous mes avocats mes agents mes amis et
son parti et a personne qui me chercher
à l'hôpital ok alors j'ai dû raser ma
tête maintenant j'ai trouvé des gens se
disent d'accord ok donc il faudrait des
gens parfois des gens qui ont des
problèmes dans la vie qui ont connu vos
histoires et mon histoire et des gens
comme ça ils savent que s'ils savent
qu'ils ont peut pas accuser quelqu'un
qui était
pas ce que sont les grandes idées mon
écran dit on est pas resterait comme
acheter le coup est ce que nous ont pas
trop c'est ce que vous êtes
j'aime son assistant de délicieuses je
suis 60 millions est ce que j'aime c'est
que vous êtes homo un homo on est tous
au mont
ventoux sur mo yan homosexuels et à
l'oeil à l'omonia parce qu'on s'adore
moi je me regarde dans la glace pour
quoi pour avoir un beau corps caire l'on
m'a donné on va d'un accord et j'essaie
de respecter le mec je peux alors j'aime
mon corps est ce que je suis un homme en
moi je sais pas alors quand je vois un
homme dans une douche qui est un bon
coach d'hygiène à boncourt cela je suis
homo non je crois pas mais j'aime bien
les belles choses j'aime bien les belles
femmes les bozos jovial et les gens qui
sont intelligents ou les jeux même
d'être des nains qui ont qui savent bien
atteindre donc j'aime les gens
en fait j'en
connais
est ce que vous êtes travelo
annoncé mais pas des [__] non c'est
pas ça non mais ça ça m'intéresse pas de
me mabille en femme parce que c'est un
peu trop difficile cancan s'assied faut
fermer les jambes il faut les croisés
c'est une femme enfin moi je prends pas
les femmes parce que moi je viens des
femmes ok ce qu'ils m'ont fait alors les
hommes qui jouait la femme ceci la femme
cela est la femme d'ilounge comme cela
est en vérité celle qu'il a fait et lui
il se plaint dès lors il ya un problème
avec ça fait maintenant deux mille
envers les guerres on répète les mêmes
bière toujours on est toujours au jardin
d'enfants alors je trouve qu'un homme et
une femme devraient un peu plus son
s'entendre un homme doit être sensible
comme une femme est une femme sorte
comme un homme comme ça ils ont les deux
qualités ensemble ça fait lignac et ça
fait un couple sur moi et ma femme
jean cau sans fil me répliqua
merci
d'avoir été avec nous mais à bientôt je
suis là je sais la place j'aime bien le
contact
à voir
bye
[Applaudissements]
obama
haïti à la route quand vous le trouvez
julien a bien suppléé par un titre bien
dans ce sens qu'elle d'énergie non tu as
fait correctement mon plein d'énergie
c'est une pile électrique électrique
alors bon puis finalement il est marrant
ouais
c'est vrai
magnéto cette voie là on a va avoir un
petit problème tous les deux ans pour
essayer de résoudre comment va le
résoudre j'ai pas on va improviser banon
peut pas improviser là vous allez me
dire voulais pas faire ça je vais jeter
le bouquin voilà déjà fait une fois on
va trouver un compromis qu'est ce que
vous allez faire
je vais faire un effort à vous aussi
mais moi je fais tous les efforts que
vous voulez moi je bon d'avoir alors
c'est compliqué avec montebourg docter
sur le coup bien bien entendu le ghsr
allah sait comment on fait sophie
montrer l'exemple à ben de boer
et j'en ferai deux bords
j'ai aussi de votre proposition qu'on
voulait
ça commence bien c'est comment il faut
faire montrez-lui geneviève
vous sortez un nouvel album il dit vous
savez comment on fait geneviève
c'est comment on fait j'aime bien voulu
montrer
alors là je vais vous expliquer je crois
que mon ami paul quastana vous avez dit
qu'en course on souffrait d'un mal
endémique qui l'arthrose de l'épaule
s'est étendue jusqu'aux poignets alors
vous ne disposerez de le faire soyez
gentil je t'ai pas le livre je vais pas
le faire parce que c'est l'assassinât de
votre ami je vous en remercie voilà ça
serait autre chose le g13
bah oui c'est une raison c'est comment
on fait geneviève heureusement quelques
mots mais j'étais salarié
c'est lui pourrait le faire
continuez messieurs
églantine
eméyé n'est pas sûr c'est un plaisir
pour tout le monde vit pièce où l'avait
embrassé les pires et légendes rapide
des cas bien alors une cantine je suis
ravi de vous voir parce que en fait
j'adorais manger des yaourts le matin à
toile dans ma cuisine
mais jamais vu moi je vous voyais tous
les matins mangez-moi yaourts à poil en
vous regardant dans un npa matin voilà
c'est désolant parce que c'est fini et
voilà ouais tu faire toi le matin moi je
vais regarder qui continuent à manger
des yaourts est d'accord mais si vous
êtes plus sur l'écran c'est beaucoup
moins drôle marché parce que si ce sont
les télétubbies que vous pouvez faire
c'est moins excitant vous faites quoi la
rentrée alors je sais pas encore non non
je vais je vais voir j'ai des
propositions à droite à gauche mais vous
ai fait un pilote là avec votre ami de
voize pour tf1 pour l'émission qui
s'appelle shocking d'accord alors fait
monsieur michel le fils comme a fait 1
et 2 voit ce qu'on a fait donc voilà
exactement il se demande chez tf1 qui
vont prendre voilà la question s'est
bien passé ah oui oui ça s'est bien
passé votre rêve à la télé c'est quoi
dites moi peut-être que et quads agathe
quelque chose ouais je sais pas vraiment
en fait j'essaie des choses j'aimerais
faire des interviews - effectivement de
personnes apprendre à les connaître
vraiment
c'est pas une question pour voir
imaginons que ce soit la fiche 69
n'importe quelle question qui vous vient
à l'esprit
vous avez vous sait combien de temps là
sur moi vous avez préparé combien de
temps combien de temps j'ai préparé
votre interview que vous allez voir ça
demande du temps
quatre ans de travail j'ai envie de vous
avoir dans l'émission et je suis page du
passé deux heures mais pas non plus la
carrière d'une me mettre d'accord bien
alors peut-être j'ai pas envie de faire
de télé en même temps non à bastille
sinon je suis là parce que vous dénoncez
très bien oui j'ai fait beaucoup de
danse et mathieu sodore des petits
grains de beauté comme cindy crawford
alors vous avez 28 ans
jamais parlé de son alsace et non c'est
juste que c'est pas vrai j'ai 27 ans
avant c'est ça ça va non mais vous êtes
né en 73 quoi
vous avez 27 ans et demi mais tient à
toulouse famille de huit enfants
jeunesse aux quatre coins du monde père
fonctionnaire vous effet la nouvelle
calédonie vous avez fait des plats
devant nouvelle calédonie la guadeloupe
montreuil mais sur mer angers dakar en
as en commun on a beaucoup déménagé moi
aussi mais mon coeur des fonds publics
beaucoup bougé
un
pas bougé c'est pour ça
bac à 16 ans oui vous venez à paris avec
vos frères et soeurs pendant vos parents
sont encore en afrique fait une maîtrise
de sciences éco vous devenez mannequin
et puis un jour comment s'est passé le
casting chez canal parce que quand vous
êtes mannequin vous fait des tonnes de
casting comme ça et en france vous
demandez même plus pourquoi c'est et je
suis arrivé un jour dans un truc de
canal qui s'appelle canal idée m'a fait
tourner une petite vidéo ne posait pas
de question comme ça je savais vraiment
pas pourquoi c'était et voilà je suis
reparti et puis finalement alain de
greef m'a téléphoné en me vouland de
rencontrer et voilà je les rencontre et
voilà et voilà et le casting c'était qua
non de demander de parler de moi c'est
tous des questions
tu aimes pas la météo toi
donc cédé pour succéder à cécile siméone
la grande cécile siméone
quel temps il va faire demain à voir si
vous avez appris quelque chose de cet
été où
vous avez fait durant plus de fait une
formation à météo france trois jours
incroyable puis le matin après qu'on ait
fait npa matin fait se lever à 4h année
c'est une fille courage et un frère du
matin et on se couche à quelle heure
pour se lever à 4 heures
et encore si je pouvais je me serais
chercher plutôt vous avez pas eu des
expériences sexuelles pendant un an
les week-ends
oui et mais il faudrait avoir quelqu'un
qu'il est même pas du temps pour ça
comment va la grande famille de canal a
en ce moment pas très bien vous le savez
c'est il ya beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup
de priestess les gens sont un petit peu
perdues il vous en donner de l'argent
que vous êtes partie par partie avant
ils vont vous en donner je sais pas si
je vais encore parc avant à vous risquez
de rester mais un problème un génial
c'est qu'on n'a pas d'infos
les mêmes infos vous oui
bien alors avant de faire cette émission
vous avez dit à la production
d'émissions à catherine barma je ne veux
pas de questions sur ma vie privée je ne
veux pas d'interview q je ne veux pas
d'interview canadien avait demandé le
même trait balladur avait demandé
exactement la même chose
mais les comme vous c'est à dire
l'interview chatte
[Applaudissements]
donc interview chatte
quelle est la durée de gestation d'une
chatte
voulait pas d'accord
le rôle que j'ai toutes les réponses
qu'est la durée de gestation d'une
chatte pire c'est que j'en sais rien je
peux alors trois mois non 2 d'oran oui
je te dédie à huit semaines combien de
téton à une chatte 6 8 8 bravo
il connaît en chatte combien de chat
alors combien de chatons peut avoir une
chatte
8 non mais bizarrement non converties
jusqu'à 12 10 10 pourquoi est ce qu'on
ne l'avait jamais une chatte parce que
c'est la sq m pourquoi
moi je sais pas parce que c'est la
toussaint que voilà parce qu'elle se
lève tous les jours avec sa langue
râpeuse
combien de temps je vous répondais très
bien sa place j'aurais pris d'interview
n'a pas voulu
combien de temps dure la relation
sexuelle d'une chatte ça doit te rapide
ça oui
trente secondes non un peu plus
pas une minute
mais j'aimerais savoir tire ça nous
mettrait deux minutes non mais on m'a
demandé à un vétérinaire et tout ça mais
on a fait ça très lumineux
alors est-ce qu'une chatte aime être
caressé
je sais pas moi je pose
c'est ce que
je dirai oui
bah oui préfet diesel après nécessaires
à la wii tout à fait la mienne en tout
cas
bon
passez juniac l'air
je vous demande de vous arrêter
je vous demande de vous arrêter c'est
quoi le secret de votre forme ce que je
voyais là attendre à côté de la grande
caméra du minceur du 9-2 welt comment
vous faites je crois je fais attention à
ce que je mange pas de cigarettes n'ont
pas d'alcool petit peu
pas d'autres drogues noms du sport oui
l'heure m'a dit un truc que avant de
manger vous posiez vos aliments mais en
or mais c'est une rumeur à vous si on
m'a dit julien clerc tu vas vite tu
l'invite à la maison il arrive avec sa
balance je la mènerai pas chez vous à
bord à l'époque le diététicien que j'ai
plus vu depuis trois ans me disait
heureusement que j'en ai pas beaucoup
comme vous en liberté donc je lui
plaisais pas trop que je passe tout
comme ça ouais mais il faut vous dire
que comme il m'a fait un truc diététique
finalement donc c'est extrêmement simple
c'est très très peu de grâce et puis
beaucoup de féculents de légumes verts
ne marche pas
la vraie question c'est est ce qu'il
vaut mieux vivre longtemps se font chier
ou moins longtemps en bouffant n'importe
quoi le truc c'est que je ne fais pas
chier du tout à ça me semble un peu de
peser la bouffe non ah oui c'est une
nature qu'il soit voilà alors c'est un
devoir
alors vous dites j'ai bien clair j'ai
beaucoup planqué l'être humain c'est
vrai qu'on très discret sur vous même je
peux même pas de votre vie privée mais
sur vous vous êtes allé pas comme ça vos
sentiments dans la presse la télévision
parce que vous méfier de la célébrité
vous êtes toujours méfié la célébrité
n'est ce pas que je me méfie tu ça mais
c'est pas j'étais content de faire ce
métier ce que j'ai pas trop quoi faire
d'autre mais disons que dès que j'ai
commencé j'ai commencé tôt j'avais 20
ans je vais envie d'être connue pour ce
que je faisais à la papa tellement pour
les signes extérieurs de de la célébrité
c'est sympa aussi mais ce qui
m'importait dès le début c'était d'être
respectée pour la musique quoi aimé
parce que vous faites oui mais alors là
quand on fait de la promo vous êtes bien
obligé d'un petit peu venir elle est en
émoi une corvée qu'avant beaucoup moins
ah bon vous y prenez du plaisir
maintenant - rask vous savez faire
saliver
quelle discipline ce soir la dernière
émission de l'année souligne anne le
gars joue je sais pourquoi c'est quoi ce
gadget qui garent à tout à l'heure
j'espère c'est pas un truc j'espère que
c'est pas un truc quand chance et pas
trop chaud non car il venait si je
excuse
parent le vert
bah
si je t'aime
par hamas
à suivre
la mélodie comme d'habitude très bonne
et les paroles on va en parler sont pas
mal non plus et alors votre votre épouse
ne va pas eu peur de voir travailler
avec
moi je ferais si je disais à ma femme
demain je vais bosser et carla bruni
j'aurai des soucis quand même non ah non
non elle est venue beaucoup à la maison
et en fait jamais de texte joint nom
vous dit j'ai essayé mais j'étais
mauvais j'ai pas de style ouais mais ça
c'est vrai j'ai fait six de moins que
maintenant un jet lucide ah oui il ya
plein de gens qui n'ont pas cette
lucidité qui continue à écrire vous moi
vous savez vous n'êtes pas été compliqué
les choses pardon la liste est trop
longue non mais c'est vrai dit j'ai même
du mal à écrire une lettre oui c'est
vrai alors je vous dis à chaque fois que
je vois mais je vous le redis encore une
fois c'est qu'en fait effectivement on
parle beaucoup de votre vos parolier on
parle pas assez à mon sens du mélodiste
que vous êtes alors là on va écouter en
deux fois j'ai on est obligé de faire en
deux fois avec vous il ya tellement de
mélodies enfants deux fois en fait de
petits paquets de 15
tu
à
plume après ren samoa
oui je sais cette indifférence qui de sa
défense fait souvent france mais quand
elle est
à mimizan
me de faïence de faïence
s'est scindé frei travail
elle se produit
bravo
non
[Musique]
ça
je vous
je vous aime
mais voulait
toujours
je suis pas
[Musique]
la ville
et moi une glace à ce montant du
et si jeta gars si je suis trop nu jeu
tout pas
tous mr tutti
boubli je veux être utile à ceux qui
monte mais
à ceux qui m'aiment rond
et à ceux qui m'aiment
pas sûr
le vernis heures si je t'aime
m'en excuse
j'ai eu à coeur
non
content de voir qu'on demande pardon je
n'ai reconnu une
selle pour la pluie pour les tampons
c'est vrai que ces chansons là car cette
publicité qui a relancé la chanson ouais
c'est vrai qu'a annoncé le tampon
votre vie
la barrière c'est pas génial qui confond
toujours l'odeur
bien alors j'essayais de comprendre
comment tout ça va c'est vrai vous êtes
vais quand même un intérêt exceptionnel
et comment c'était arrivé c'est vrai
qu'au départ il est comme une opposition
entre deux styles de vie donc de style
de musique qui ont créé à la rencontre
des deux c'est un peu comme les beatles
quand ils font du rock and roll et puis
d'un jour encontre georges martin qui
leur dit voilà il ya le hautbois il ya
le violoncelle donc ils commencent à
mélanger le rock'n'roll avec des
instruments compliqué et vous
effectivement il ya à la fois une
inspiration j'irai française très
classique est à la fois vos origines
guadeloupéennes même si c'est loin fondé
ce sens comme ça de la mélodie à
travailleuses et tous de la musique
classique aussi beaucoup moi parce que
j'ai une formation classique sous genre
je fais des harmonies classique ouais au
départ il ya deux familles et votre
famille paternelle un inspecteur des
postes de le perdre votre père donc mais
qui est veuf qui élève son fils à la
force du poignet un cercueil je crois
que même sa femme meurt comme mon père
est très jeune et mon grand-père
internet et quelqu'un quelqu'un assez
austère qui travaillait comme vous dites
dans les postes dont toute la jeunesse
devant peur c'était des études très
brillante des chicanes il a fait normale
sup en fait c'est quelqu'un qui a été
élevé comme ça dans ce sens là et en
face alors c'est assez minces comme le
film de chatiliez quoi dire qu'on fasse
et il nous de famille beaucoup plus
folklo votre salut maternelle hors sas
et les antilles et votre votre père qui
guadeloupéen grand père maternel au père
guadeloupéen il est communiste aussi il
est venu pour regarde 14 il est resté
vais surtout faisait pas tort de dire en
face c'est que c'est vraiment de l'autre
côté de la rue c'est la rue poirier
denard c'est qu'une petite rue dans
quatre séances main et ma grand mère
maternelle vient faire le ménage c'est
mon grand père paternel
c'est insensé alors quand elle vient à l
emmène sa fille et petite fille est tout
petit
viens chez leclerc alors le fils leclerc
lui prête ses stylos et crayons sans
papiers et donc il dessine tous les deux
voilà maintenant lui à 15 ans il fait
ses devoirs sérieux et et puis la petite
fille d'un côté et pour qu'elle lui
[__] la paix pendant que ma grand mère
fait le ménage il bidone des crayons
papier puis la guerre arrive et y
revient et c'est une belle jeune fille
va dans la grande île et voilà c'est
comme une histoire comme un roman
j'adore ça tourne tous des romans ma vie
est un roman on pourrait dire et c'est
vrai dire que là il revient de la guerre
il trouve cette petite gamine qui
dessinaient y trouve une jolie jeune
fille il épouse d'un des enfants
l'enfant qui n'essaie vous voilà c'est
paul alain alors paul c'était votre père
alain c'était votre mère et leclerc
c'était votre nom évidemment elles sont
déjà pas d'accord sur le prénom de leur
fils donc ça présage rien de bon faut
bien le dire il se sépare quelques
quelques années plus tard je dois avoir
un an un an et demi oui c'est pas
beaucoup plus tard et dans votre père
lui la une vous garde en fait un il est
haut fonctionnaire à l'unesco alors là
il va habiter dans une maison là voilà
on est en plein film de chatiliez là
c'est à dire que la vie est un long
fleuve tranquille dans la maison aux
molières avant la boa pour la reine et
l'autre côté avec la belle-mère qui
scella vous apprenez la musique
classique a été formidable oui de
vieilles chansons françaises la musique
classique et tout cela tout la musique
classique avait pas de télévision peu de
radios ouais ouais la musique classique
et quand on chante avec mes frères et
soeurs autour du piano de temps en temps
le square des chansons françaises les
vieilles chansons alors du côté de
bodmer sais pas si ma mère ça s'est
blessé le jazz et le blues est comme mon
grand père va verne dernis pour sa
retraite elle continue de vivre dans ce
petit appartement les femmes seules
secrétaire de direction et je la vois
pendant les week-ends et là il ya la
télé les disques de chansons et c'est
autre chose tout ça
est alors comme quoi chez tout artiste
c'est une fêlure au départ et quelque
part quelque chose qui s'est mal passé
vous ces déchirements du dimanche soir
quand vous retournez de la porte
d'orléans à bourg-la-reine à pied vous
dites depuis je déteste l'hiver on prend
prenez le métro pour marcher de de la
gare de bourg la reine jusqu'à la maison
et avait comme ça 20 minutes oui là je
voyais ma mère pleurait effectivement un
certain j'ai détesté l'automne
c'est une odeur dans l'automne en
banlieue fin dans les banlieues je dois
dire d'ailleurs plutôt les banlieues où
il ya des marronniers en fait état des
odeurs qui me suivront certainement
toute ma vie et je déteste ça l'arrivée
de l'hiver tous à l'automne non mais tu
as quand même ma mère pleurait quand
comme ça jusqu'à la maison vous vivez
dans deux mondes complètement opposées
d'un côté les influences antillaise avec
le point colombo la confiture d'ananas
l'actionnaire de l'autre côté de votre
père qui était gaulliste ouais assez
assez assez pur et dur est votre seule
évasion ou par rapport à ces deux
univers c'est la musique quand arrivent
les tarifs des beatles par yves
l'avant j'ai pu écouter quand on m'a
offert j'avais
mes parents avaient choisi comme parrain
un juif un
monsieur qui était radiologue
juifs roumains et
évidemment il avait un enfant unique et
alors une gâté énormément j'étais
pas mal d'argent et alors c'est lui le
premier qui m'a offert un poste
transistors alors après da au lycée
lakanal ya un pote antilles et qui
s'appelle socrates qui vous initie à la
batterie et là vous jouez dans des
groupes vous dites c'est davantage
d'avoir un côté bourgeois c'est le côté
bourg la reine ça vous jouez dans des
rallyes dont vous faites un peu vous
faites un peu de thunes quand j'avais
des copines et des copains qui était
qu'ils étaient tous structuraliste et
bien enfin ne nous écoutait pas
tellement ce qu'on jouait ce n'était pas
très bon on joue un peu mieux disent et
ce
pour hâter sciences po à cause de léon
blum ouais et puis après vous avez la
fac à censier là vous avez votre pote de
lakanal bon il fallait vous essayer à
composer à la composition déjà et vous
reprenez le piano vous avez abandonné à
l'âge de 13 ans et plus vont essayer et
comment ça c'est ce qui m'intéresse
c'est comment vous est pris conscience
que vous pouvez écrire des mélodies et
je sens ça s'est passé et je vais vous
dire que quand j'ai repris le piano tout
seul évidemment je voulais plus de profs
comme j'en avais une idole joué pourtant
de paris de solfège sais je faisais que
des trucs à l'oreille et comme vous vous
en doutez bien j'aime et des musiques
qui étaient des musiques pas facile donc
j'essayais comme je pouvais de
reproduire les accords mais quand il
fallait reproduire thelonious monk ou
bobby timmons qui sont des grands
pianistes de jazz j'avais le plus grand
mal ce n'est pas les clés de cette
musique donc évidemment un jour en
cherchant vraisemblablement sur un truc
de tonus mon cou de dylan ou des beatles
je sais plus
je crois que de guerre lasse
je vais essayer de trouver de la visite
pour moi tout et je pense vraiment que
ma vie a basculé le jour je me suis
rendu compte vous pouviez composé
composer et saint dont il sera la mère
de pouvoir composer des mélodies j'ai
pris conscience un jour vous muriel que
vous aviez un don ou ces huit artistes a
commencé dans la voiture en faisant rire
qui m'intéressait c'était celui de la
musique parce que j'écoutais je m y
jouer pareil ouais vous savez quand elle
joue de la batterie vachement bien mais
je les ai vus jouer un jour satisfaction
ah bon c'est pas
c'est pas une grande technicienne mais
elle a une énergie à l'après nergie
débatteurs
non mais ça non vous êtes le seul ici en
avoir vu le jour il raconté alors un
jour placé la scène alors fondatrice de
l'histoire
comme sa mère elle est nommée juge et de
réparer le décor
pour alice
non mais c'est d'ailleurs un jour les
une histoire quand même c'est
extraordinaire ça aussi dans money la
vie des gens ça me fait sinon je vous
êtes à la sorbonne par côté de la
sorbonne dans un petit café qui
s'appelle l'écritoire vous êtes
incapable d'écrire des paroles avec vale
vous vous levez comme ça et vous dites
je suis chanteur qui veut écrire mes
chansons et à ce moment là quelqu'un qui
écrit des paroles à et le mec qui répond
c'est roda-gil quand même et là c'est
fou quand même mais qui se lèvent cerda
ginette en train de faire des petits
portraits façon cocteau sur une table ça
il est l'instigateur déjà il faut être
dessinateur absolument sûrement elle dit
moi c'est parti
hama
il
il va la vie
hélas
non
[Applaudissements]
fitch est là
il y a
et
sur l'eau
je suis
moi
m
[Applaudissements]
ce
n'est rien
je sais
m
j
je n'ai vu
fini de la
véranda
je vous
aucune choix
deux cents
[Musique]
lui non
au parlement rené vieux par l'enfant
[Musique]
could en mai
voilà
ah si on chantait
je
elle vous là que je l'appelle venir 20
vimont
dallier
[Musique]
et voilà
comme très sérieuse
en faire une interview prise de tête
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bien non
je sais pas ce que mathieu gazel
lukas gerber toute la soirée je sais pas
quel prix je leur ai payé mais je la
cherche c'est après cette petite de
l'apec tu as ce soir-là prend des
vacances même qui va chier manos
vient alors à se prendre un peu la tête
sur des sujets sérieux julien clerc est
ce que vous êtes favorable au droit de
vote pour les immigrés j'avais averti
ses prises de tête oui oui
même s'il ya des gens qui payent des
impôts en france non pas le voilà donc
ça c'est pas normal penser que les
assassins enfants méritent la peine de
mort alors ça évidemment c'était
c'est une question que je me pose c'est
parce que j'ai j'ai fait une chanson moi
là dessus sur la peine de mort est
évidemment c'est un débat terrible et je
devrais vous répondre au nom puisque jeu
quand on est contre la peine de mort on
est contre la peine de mort est un temps
quand on a des enfants oui on a envie de
de penser le contraire
voilà mais enfin disons que je suis
contre la peine de mort je continue de
l'être si l'un de vos proches souffrait
d'un mal incurable est-ce que vous soyez
favorables à l'euthanasie si la personne
en expriment le besoin
évidemment
si elle le mentionne si elle le demande
c'est le réclament oui l'avortement
mais l'avortement je suis évidemment
pour l'avortement
simplement je crois que c'est dire que
par exemple je crois qu'il faut essayer
de tout faire pour en arriver là voilà
mais sinon c'est un droit c'est une
nécessité
c'est savez de même moi j'ai toujours
pensé que c'était les femmes qui
décident et d'avoir les enfants et bien
elles peuvent elles peuvent décider
aussi le contraire on peut en avoir ça
c'est un droit absolument qui ne devra
pas discuter je vous est favorable à
l'adoption d'enfants par dés couples
homosexuels
je pense que les enfants ont besoin
d'amour
mais en même temps c'est vrai que
on peut réfléchir à ça on peut on peut
j'ai vu des films magnifiques déjà enfin
les très jolis films d'actualités là
dessus je réfléchirai avant mais si vous
me demandez de mettre un bulletin
dans l'yonne je crois qu'on finirait par
dire oui
je suis si tu pensé que c'est un crime
contre soi même c'est un droit
je pense qu'il faut vachement de courage
moi je suis cité
mais ce n'est quand la peine de marche
pas pourquoi on pourrait s'appliquer à
soi
n'ont maintenant plus de dix ans
le suicide c'est quand quelqu'un
celui-ci c'est qu'il est trop mal il ya
des choses qui ne peut plus regarder ce
qu'il ne peut plus vivre des choses qui
ne en payant des mots simples de la
langue française qui ne supportent plus
tout simplement
décision pour les autres nous notre pas
là dedans on n'a pas à juger ça vous
croyez pas en dieu vous
j'aimerais bien par moments ça serait
plus facile en particulier dans votre
dans votre questionnaire quand on croit
en dieu on a d un chemin tout tracé non
malheureusement alors je jeu j'aime
beaucoup les gens qui croient qu'une
union qui ont la foi en même temps j'ai
été heureux de
heureux j'étais je ne nie pas j'ai été
élevé là dedans on même si on ne
pratiquait pas beaucoup en faire en
d'autres termes j'ai été heureux de
maria l'église quand le moment était
venu de 2,2 me marier je pars à l'église
tous les dimanches mais je suis issu de
cette culture langue et j'admire les
gens qui croient mois malheureusement
vous y croyez pas alors c'est un truc
bien vis j'y crois pas et même quand
l'avion commence un peu à bouger comme
ça j d'une croix toujours pas quoi oui
et non c'est à dire
non mais c'est vrai je vais
mais ça serait se renier aussi se met à
prier tout vous êtes en ligne j'essaie
toujours les j'essaie d'être cohérent à
peu près du rial vous dans l'avion bouge
très vite
sortir voilà
que tu vas mourir c'était à prier c'est
un exercice pour faire entrer un peu
hésitant j'ai dans un avion fait voilà
ce test c'est une baisse de l'avion
qu'il bouge avec ce qui n'est pas non
plus dans la viande
d'inventer son pari avait pris l'avion
oui là encore c'est la sq à lui disait
tu te mets à genoux tu pries et un jour
tu croiras c'est autre chose
[Musique]
jeune auteur
elle sévit en chine
magnéto serre est-ce que vous avez vous
married et nous non c'est pas
imaginez vous un homme m'approche vous
savez ce qu'il risque depuis quatre ans
alors des bons pneus quand way et finir
avec
judiciaire les ânes ont ensuite apprécié
on va faire un test on va le tenter
demain contrôle fiscal
bafouait décourager des graphes toi je
pénétrai
les emmerder mangerai le lendemain les
bons jeunes ex patron du csa bonsoir
monsieur le président patron du c'est ça
du tout président des présidents est
pourquoi ça monsieur hervé bourges ici
bien des branchements soir comptoir
là
mon
j'accueille à de l'amendé
la belle fille témoin le mariole via un
prince un curé là ce soir
alors
qu'après s'il parle comme ça on derrière
l'équipe
non non on va relever le niveau rassurez
vous alain maillard de la morandais on
doit vous appeler mon père si vous êtes
mon fils oui oui bah je vous appelle mon
père alors très bien je vous êtes
catholique je crois oui je suis
catholique oui mon père
bien alors vous êtes né en 1935 au
croisic éducation traditionnelle voire
traditionalistes alors vous avez été
élevé dans la mythologie de la anti
révolutionnaires contre révolution des
révolutionnaires sert qu'à l'époque on
vous expliquer la terreur vous avez été
élevé dans le culte des chouans non loin
de là la résolution i les charrettes
sont des cousins oui c'est ça oui c'est
vraiment voilà alors c'est vrai il faut
dire quand même que bon tout ça n'est
pas non plus innocent c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque sur la loire on mettait des
gens dans des bateaux et on perd c'est
le fond ces fameux carrier qui dressa
donc est quand même des raisons le yacht
de la loi voilà la terreur en eaux
froides voilà est aussi le génocide
vendéen qui est reconnu comme un
génocide alors quand vous avez 24 ans
vous donnez séminaristes à rome
par vosges et après l'italien voilà le
temps benzema
honnêtement quand vous devenez
séminaristes et l'âge de 24 ans avant
mais ce que c'est par vocation parce que
le milieu dans lequel vous aviez été
élevé vous y poussent c'est une bonne
question ô mon seigneur
les deux mois il ya une vraie vocation
qui vient de la lecture d'un auteur à
thé dieu se sert de tout y compris les
athées parfois des princes pour appeler
à lui je n'avais pas envie d'être curé
ça c'est certain mais dans le contexte
de l'époque aller jusqu'au bout de
l'absolu et de dieu c'est sfr prêtre
ouais vous aviez vraiment la foi quoi ao
complètement sa pas varié d'un pouce au
contraire elle augmente chaque jour et
même en vous voyant
et
comme chante si bien ophélie winter dieu
lui a donné la foi en fait des études de
philo de théologie à l'époque alors on
faisait trois ans de philo ensuite en
service militaire en faisait quatre ans
de théologie bien ça fait sept ans 28
mois d'algérie 28 mois d'algérie alors à
l'époque la rumeur courait déjà qu'on
pratiqué la torture en algérie voyez à
cause de votre éducation vous ne pouviez
pas y croire parce que pour vous les
officiers c'était le symbole de
l'honneur de la civilisation et vous
trouviez scandaleux même qu'on puisse
les soupçonner de torture et les
officiers français tout à fait j'étais
dans la mythologie de lyautey de
larigaudie enfin des grands noms que les
jeunes ne connaissent pas ton chéri cox
gras et donc imaginé un officier
français en train de torturer c'est à
dire d'attenté à la dignité de la
personne humaine me paraissait
absolument
impossible ouais ouais et en fait quand
vous arrivez en algérie vous découvrez
effectivement que l'armée française
pratiquer la torture c'est lui être un
choc terrible pour eux c'est un choc
c'est pas le seul choc est aussi la
misère il y avait du monde oui et puis à
l'idhec à 18 ans un jeune algérien
devant les carences de la colonisation
française ne pouvait prendre que son
fugier aller dans le djebel donc je
découvre ce qu'est la révolution ouais
bon effectivement 28 mois en algérie
comme officier vous luttez contre la
torture vous luttez ensuite contre
l'abandon des harkis parce que ça aussi
il faut le dire c'est comme une noyade
dans la loire il faut tout dire quand
l'histoire faut dire quand même que la
france a abandonné 150000 harkis en
algérie qui ont été égorgés
dès que les français sont partis en 62
voilà alors on vous menace à l'époque on
vous dit oui mais vous vous révolter
contre la torture c'est pas bon pour
votre dossier à rome ce serait mauvais
pour ma carrière oui j'ai pas changé
depuis ouais non il avait à la panoplie
des mecs tu as réussi à rome il est pas
déguiser en waterman
en tous les cas ça vous a pas empêché
effectivement non je dis oh pas de
réussir mais enfin quand même de faire
une carrière au sein de l'église a
qu'une réussite
et vous chez laffont aussi au jugement
dernier jeu passera c'est patrick uldry
c'est pour ça qu'il ya l'impression
de sortir la gold coast
l'audimat c'est gentil mais ça ne fait
que marcher oui par rapport au jugement
dernier ne fait rien alors en 63 vous
est ordonné prêtre
ensuite vous cofondé radio notre dame
vous écrivez un livre sur la torture en
algérie en 90 mais personne n'a parlé
c'était à londres est pas la mort en 92
ou devenez l'aumônier du monde politique
à l'initiative du cardinal lustiger est
ce que vous étiez un peu on pourrait
dire le représentant du lobby catho tout
à fait je revendique le maul au but j'ai
écrit un article dans le figaro là
dessus au moment où monsieur d'ormesson
a prononcé ce mot et que certains autres
lobbies sont scandalisés comme chantal
par exemple eh eh bien j'ai dit oui et
pourquoi et pourquoi il n'y aurait pas
un lobby catho ouais vous étiez les
formations voilà oui vous représentez
vous qu'est ce que vous faisiez vous
organisez des allées des petits fours et
grande soirée d'amitié les hommes
politiques annoncées pas à côté petit
four et moulin noir c'était du vrai
boulot hein on était consultant
théologique way premier les hommes
politiques oui tout à fait donc chaque
groupe parlementaire en général un
référent il ya le dr un tel que je pige
halliche de tels partis etc mais
d'autres ont envie de se faire une idée
il s'appelle le consultant est d'accord
et ils disent vont expliquer nous un
petit peu à la limite y en a qui nous
dise comment il faut voter ouais je dis
non mais j'ai pas là pour vous dire
comment il faut voter j'éclaire votre
lanterne et vous êtes tout seul pour
voter il alors dit moi mon père vous
habiller les les confessions des hommes
politiques il n'est ce qu'on fait c'est
chez vous à ce style qu'ancien de votre
parcours une question plus originales et
alors qu'est ce qui vous raconter la
colle la confession sa 200 salles chance
purement sacramentelle on va voir le
prête on dit chez pêchions demande le
pardon de dieu chez le secret
professionnel absolu ça c'est le rite
sacramentelle et il ya les confessions
dans le sens large du terme ou un homme
politique vient me dire j'ai un problème
parce que ma femme chèque je te que je
la trompe
mes enfants j'ai quitté l'islam et
crois que j'ai très peur
à propos de la durite
bavure
on
m'a dit qu'ils échappent énormément
non je tâche est plutôt un mec
moralement par marc bien alors j'ai pas
faire campagne chercher un autre
sérieusement quand il veut et ce qu'on
fait c'est en dehors de leur affaire de
sexe est-ce qui vous disaient des fois
j'ai détourné de l'argent mon père je
suis désolé mais il ya eu des problèmes
de corruption mais j'ai été le confident
ouais alors on vous a accusé à l'époque
vous étiez donc l'aumônier du monde
politique d'être intrigant
beaucoup et on vous attend vous à taxer
de balladurisme à attention attention
attention je suis en train de porter
plainte contre un une journaliste qui
ressort ce propos diffamatoires
j'entends depuis cinq ans oui je sais
c'est pour ça que je vais là répondait
là vous êtes vous êtes à la télé eh bien
je crois en toi mon fils je dis non
avant non dits ontologiquement pendant
les présidentielles je n'ai parlé ni de
jacques delors avec qui j'avais
d'excellents rapports mieux qu'avec
balladur je n'ai parlé ni jak2 veulent
edouard balladur ni de jacques chirac
les chiraquiens vous êtes d'accord vous
ont reproché d'être balladuriens ça les
arrangeait way puis qu'il avait peur de
balladur ouais vas balla diouf vous a
quand même fait chevalier de la légion
d'honneur oui et j'ai même demandé au
cardinal chute je vais accepter m'a
répondu oui parce que l'on honore la
fonction que moi j'ai créé un bon
d'accord donc le cardinal était d'accord
bien rage l'avait refusé au départ voilà
donc
vous daignez tout à fait 7 a
complètement si je porte plainte en
diffamation contre une journaliste puis
cinq adhérents si quelqu'un si quelqu'un
traite alain de la morandais de balladur
ici vous pensiez ballade you lie
part faible en bataille
tension laurent la vengeance qui vident
bonjour
en revanche jean calvin alors recompter
vous reprend très bien on va les laisser
au repos obligatoire selon
sanaa où cache un jeu puisque dans
l'éternité le temps ne compte pas voilà
c'est quoi la fin d'été en été je
comprends il ya enfin des terres si peu
angoissant alors vous me connais pas
alors et justement ce week-end un
meilleur chose dont jamais de fin sauf
les émission d'ardisson
alors vous êtes débarquer
les jours de séminaire pour gaza c'est
un bosseur
philosophie théologie sept ans à rome
vous êtes
mon père vous êtes débarqué par lustiger
quand même à un moment parce que
pourquoi parce qu'ils n'arrivent plus à
vous défendre auprès de chirac je n'ai
pas de comptes à régler avec mon patron
pourquoi parce que les ennemis de
l'église serait trop content de
récupérer la chose au match donc je ne
dis rien on voit qu'il est élevé à rome
quand même récupérer les choses à ma
bouche et syndicaux
alors on peut dire est ce qu'on peut
dire que vous êtes en pénitence depuis
cinq ans ah oui par rapport au franc non
il tend pénitents entraîneur mais seriez
depuis cinq ans vous avez plus de
fonctions vous vous occupez d'une
chapelle qui s'appelle la chapelle
l'agneau de dieu qui a été construite
sur l'îlot de chalon ouais à l'endroit
où on a cherché longtemps elle va
parfois mais oui c'est vrai
comment vous savez ça
il est fort exactement où j'ai acheté de
la poudre à l'époque c'est vrai que la
reine et koné et maintenant il ya une
église voilà et voilà la norme il ya
aussi beaucoup de hdf ouais vous venez
en aide aux sans abri aussi il faut que
je travaille beaucoup là dessus et vous
publiez un avis vous savez comment on
fait mon père non
je vous dire un truc di falco l'a fait
mais il est prêt à tout
mais pas facile mais moi non le pape il
a fait mais pas exprès au pardon oui là
celle alors là je prends trois ans de
purgatoire est pas là dessus je suis
content élever le débat moi j'ai peur du
jugement dernier opus a bien alors
voulait pas faire douter l'un d'oiseaux
bombe à emmanuel fait ses petits gimat
le prince le fait à la place du reggae
mon père délégué
bien on a gagné notre place voilà
alors le livre s'appelle la communion
des [__] sécher la thèse c'est votre
premier roman c'est toujours votre
obsession de la torture en algérie y a
pas que ça y'a pas que ça moi je sens
que c'est ça la rall convient méchante
8la mai 68 alors je fais le pitch ouais
laurent 16 en algérie en 61 qui assiste
à une scène de torture qui s'achève en
abus sexuels et deux mois plus tard il
est violet sur la route de saint jacques
de compostelle laurent adapté voilà il
se demande si c'est pas une punition de
la justice immanente et ensuite il l'air
à travers le monde en se réfugiant
auprès du père grégoire
il cherche la réponse à cette question
c'est une façon un peu sommaire de
résumer votre bouquin enfin alors la
première question que vous me posez
c'est est-ce que le fait d'aller faire
ce pèlerinage à saint jacques de
compostelle est-ce que c'est pas déjà
une preuve de sa culpabilité qu'il admet
sa culpabilité qu'il y va pour se grimer
vous car il a assisté sans rien dire à
cette scène de torture avait presque
tout compris jeu il fait sa propre
repentance en faisant ce pèlerinage
alors qu'il est atteint parce qu'il a
conscience qu'il aurait dû ouvrir sa
gueule ouais moi sur donc est la
communion des saints et la communion des
[__] basse et l'autre c'est ce qui
donne le titre de votre de votre roman
est ce que est ce que c'est
autobiographique c'est vite arrivé comme
vous étiez en algérie les 28 mois vous
avez passé là bas est-ce que vous avez
assisté à gc chez torture sans rien dit
j'ai été témoin non non j'ai été témoin
de chaîne sport des preuves dans ce
genre d'affaires c'est sérieux oui donc
il faut avoir des preuves j'ai été
appelé par un jeune lieutenant comme moi
qui était appelé pour dire viens voir
vite à la ferme il se passe des choses
donc je suis arrivé que la jeep et mon
officier mon ordonnance est très
rapidement j'ai vu le début j'ai fait
cherche évidemment à d'anciens et après
j'ai pu protester parce que j'avais des
preuves d'accord vous avez jamais
assisté à une scène de torture sans rien
dire c'est pas insensible massue a
reconnu dans le monde le 23 juin 2000 il
a reconnu qu'il y avait eu de la torture
et fernique et par l'armée française en
algérie il a même dit que c'était
inutile et le général bigeard a dit que
c'était un tissu de mensonges mais
bigeard il est vieux puis l'a toujours
été un peu mégalo il est déconnecté quoi
ah je vais quand même plaidé pour lui il
n'a pas eu de formation morale c'est
vrai ça coince beaucoup non mais on n'a
pas le droit d'envoyer des officiers
dans des situations difficiles
lorsqu'ils n'ont pas eu la bonne
formation pour résister à des tentations
évidente donc faut pas transformer les
militaires en boucs émissaires les
vraies responsabilités sur ce problème
elles sont du côté politique droite et
gauche confondues oui et le président
françois mitterrand à quelques
responsabilités sur laquelle j'aï
ministre de l'intérieur n'est ce pas
n'est ce pas et il fermait et je dois
dire qu'en ce que les gaullistes ne
connaissent pas leur histoire que le
général de gaulle a envoyé une
circulaire dès son arrivée au pouvoir en
58 à son ministre de la défense de
l'époque guillaume a pour interdire les
méthodes 1
alors monseigneur bérenger qui est
évêque de saint-denis oui carrément
condisciples à rome voilà a été mandatée
par le cardinal j'imagine pour gérer je
dirais la repentance par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé pendant pendant la
guerre donc le low cost et quand on lui
a dit qu'il faudrait faire la même chose
pour la guerre d'algérie pour la torture
etc les harkis il a dit il n'ya pas de
lobby en ce sens en france rim la dia
mois un jus répondu mais t'en fais pas
en créer un ouais vous pensez que
bientôt tout ça va être souhaite comme
vichy terre vichy depuis dix ans bon là
on a tout mis sur la table vous pensez
que ça va être pareil pour l'algérie ça
va se faire peu à peu ce qu'il faut
c'est que ça chauffe face calmement sans
règlement de comptes sans violence et
dans la sérénité parce que le de nîmes
le déni de mémoire n'est jamais bon pour
aucune génération il faut savoir ce
qu'on fait les grands pères les pertes
de façon à ce que les jeunes générations
soient de plus en plus franche et nette
par rapport à leurs enfants et ça on y
arrivera et là il ya un progrès est-ce
que vous pensez que le fn va faire la
même chose mais ils ont tellement de
problèmes plus graves à régler la bac
ils en sont pas là ils font un dans 50
ans ouais alors ce qui vous gêne un peu
c'est que cette initiative de repentance
sur la torture en algérie viennent les
communistes dont vous dites mais comme
saint gobain dans l on lâchait wii sont
mal placés
nous faire la leçon oui non sur pas
écouté ya le goulag il ya le fait que le
parti communiste a été à fermer sa
gueule pendant longtemps pendant la
guerre d'algérie sous le gouvernement de
guy mollet et ensuite à une attitude qui
était pas clair du tout ils ont vraiment
mis le temps alors bon il faut
repentance maintenant moi je veux bien
mais c'est pas à eux de nous donner des
leçons alors au delà des au delà de ce
problème est-ce que ça pose pas tout
simplement le problème de l'obéissance
c'est à dire c'est finalement papon tous
ces gens là il était quand même au
service d'un pouvoir politique à un
moment il ya un dos nu il ya un devoir
de désobéissance à d'accord voilà c'est
ce que je voulais entendre dire bien sûr
et donc de voir deschamps tient son camp
quand vous disiez tout à l'heure que
s'il fallait pas incriminer l'armée mais
le pouvoir politique est bien l'armé n'a
pas usé de ses pouvoirs des
désobéissants général de bollardière
attend métrage obscur l'ont fait oui
c'est à dire sans grade mais il y en a
pas tous les minorités comme d'habitude
comme d'habitude mais enfin comme de
gaulle en 40 oui des homélies et que ça
à l'armée qui est parti à londres
d'accord alors voici maintenant à au
catholicisme en france aujourd'hui il
n'est pas très bien traité on en parle
souvent ici on voit le pape aux guignols
qui prend de la coke on n'a jamais vu de
rabbins prendre de la coke aux guignols
sur canal on n'a jamais vu dit mam
prendre de la coke aux guignols sur
canal vous avez sans doute lu le livre
de rené rémy 1 est ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui donc comme rené rémond le
catholicisme en france finalement été
maltraités et traitée comme une autre il
est mal traitée mais le pire serait
qu'ils deviennent indifférent ouais donc
moi je trouve que badiou qu'on en parle
c'est bien parce que moi on peut
répondre ça doit être dur quand même
aujourd'hui d'être disons prêtre
médiatique quand on vous parle de la
capote pendant lequel vous pouvez
répondre ben je me dis que ils en sont
encore là ils n'ont pas compris quoi
expliquer nous alors le pape est chargé
de donner le top le plus haut ouais puis
après nous on gérait on gère on est à la
base on dit bah écoute tu fais ce que tu
veux si tu veux on ne peut pas vraiment
faire autre chose que de bbb en moi ne
prend pas de risques d'akena maire de
pas l'autre grave mais tu sais ce serait
mieux deux d'accord non c'est jouer le
vil débat c'est mieux de pas trompé sa
femme et sur la trompe mettons une
capote mais c'est comme la question que
j'ai entendu thaler sur les maisons
closes sur les bordels l'idéal c'est que
si tous les couples étaient heureux y
aura pas de bordeaux l1 avec des maîtres
comme menez
le mariage des packs ans tous les deux
jours dont à la télé on nous explique
qu'il ya un curé pédophile qui se tape
un gamin de 8 ans est ce que si les
prêts de se marier ce serait quand même
pas plus sain carrière du chanteur ne
change rien du tout parce qu'il ya le
même cachet des instituteurs marié ouais
donc il ya un vrai problème le problème
à la fois dans l'éducation nationale
comme dans l'église c'est d'arriver à
discerner au départ et c'est très
difficile quelles sont les tendances de
quelqu'un qui va s'occuper des plus
jeunes car souvent eux mêmes ne le
savent pas 1 à 20 ans ou à 25 ans alors
c'est là où il ya un devoir de vigilance
de la part de l'éducation nationale et
de l'église vous pensez votre premier
chef évidemment pensez pas que le
mariage des prêtres non pas entre eux
mais avec des femmes résoudrait le
résoudrait le problème mais j'ai trop de
respect pour le mariage pour penser que
ce soit un remède commun solution quand
ça ferait du bien commun en fait ce
n'est pas là c'est ici un peu comme un
bien est ce que vous pensez je n'ai rien
contre le fait que plus tard après jean
paul 2 juillet voilà des prêtres mariés
au contraire ce que je vais vous dire
est ce que vous pensez pas que mon jean
paul ii il a fait beaucoup il a déjà
détruit il a détruit le communiste puis
ce qui est déjà beaucoup alors est ce
que vous pensez pas que le jour il sera
plus là un pape un peu plus moderne
pourra être plus coulants disons surtout
s'agit pas d'être cool ans il s'agit de
changer les paramètres et les exigences
pour les rendre possible et humain vous
pensez que jean paul ii risque de
démissionner là non parce qu'il ya quand
même 183 cardinaux qui sont les deux
raisons pour lesquelles un enfant s'il
démissionnera pas pas plus que françois
mitterrand quand on est au pouvoir on
est un peu prisonnier d'un entourage
dans toujours rage a toujours intérêt à
ce que le pouvoir reste et d'en profiter
dans les meilleures sens du terme
d'ailleurs et deuxièmement c'est un
homme d'un volontarisme et dans
l'héroïsme extraordinaire donc il n'est
pas psychologiquement vraisemblable que
quelqu'un qui est volontariste héroïque
dis-je je me retire il avait
l'impression justement de faillir voir
son héroïsme vous pas pensé qu'il mourra
sur place tout à fait comme molière
alamo rendez vous êtes prêtre vous avez
croyant donc je vais vous faire une
interview croyance
dans le team
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai péché mon père j'ai bougé pour
moi la solution sera de pénitence je
crois que ma fille de ma tête non non
rires à une coupe de champagne en
sortant
est ce que vous croyez au diable oui
bien sûr quand je vous vois
[Applaudissements]
drake tailler un rire sardonique rire
diabolique via verges h c'est pire oui
aux besoins du vergès oui c'est vrai est
ce que vous croyez que la france va
gagner l'eurovision cette année
oui
évidemment parlé tout à l'heure avec
natasha st-pier ses rivaux c'est pour la
fois ouais
si vous croyez aux extraterrestres non
aux anges oui ça existe les hanches wii
auront moins esthétiquement et
poétiquement et artistiquement et
pourquoi pas sûr naturellement vrai a
raison le gardien moyen âge que je prie
toujours avant de venir une émission de
télévision vrai c'est l'ange des vanités
oui je dis chouf le mois sur la gueule
pour que je me prenne pas trop syrien
sait bien que je ne me gonfle pas de
vanité mais c'est bien c'est raté et
l'ange gardien
canadien guy
et que les agents cas de sexe bien sûr
et des anges gardiens le mot paix je
viens de plus grand qu'il y avait il
faut que j'explique au prince qui a des
plaisirs plus grands que ceux du chac ah
oui
ah ouais bah c'est un gros que tard et 3
quand il sera roi il aura besoin vous
aurez besoin d'avoir quelqu'un comme
champion andre cher bien entendu moi je
vous dit rien on voit très bien tu vois
très bien confesseur au près dans un
pouce il a rien dit sur tous les hommes
politiques mais bon tu vas invitera
après il n'y a rien c'est clair mais y'a
carlos de bourbon 1 qui me demandent
aussi des bonbons -
6/10 fait 700 personnes tous les soirs
philippe tesson dit que c'est un génie
qu'est ce que je vous dise oui il
continue est ce que vous croyez à
l'efficacité des crèmes antirides ça ne
m'intéresse pas du tout s'il a laissé
l'occasion gérard palissé de
questionnaires la saison ouais c'est bon
vous croyez à la réincarnation à la
réincarnation non je crois la
résurrection ce qui est très différent
expliquez-nous mais la réincarnation
s'imaginer que lorsqu'on a été lent
gushue a marre oui et qu'on a pêché on
va devenir ma peau dégradation de plus
en plus bas et qu'au contraire quand on
a été bien on va devenir baleines et
ensuite colibri couet alors que la
résurrection c'est lorsque vous croyez
il ya un raciste animalier terrible
pourquoi colibri cmuc baleine j'ai pas
dis que c'est une valeur la richesse et
la résurrection c'est très différent
c'est de croire qu'après la mort l'amour
est plus fort que la vie et que la
création est tellement belle qu'elle
renaîtra avec nous avec des corps mais
avec déplaisir infiniment supérieures à
résurrection des corps
bien je ne méprise pas de sexe ah non
mais j'espère bien dedans est ce que
vous croyez que chirac sera réélu en
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe j'espère qu'il y
aura un groupe qui se formera qui
s'appellera tout sauf chirac
un groupe de rock
ali dont amaury
médias bayrou qui va se présenter
d'accord c'est vrai aa c'est pas un
technocrate c'est un vrais paysans il a
fait une très belle biographie du roi
henri iv bien entendu une ambiance il
agira chine et le charisme en plus c
est peu dire qu'on n'avait pas peu dire
que bayrou si les démocrates chrétiens
quand même c'est plus votre truc quoi
mais chirac c'est à ce point là quand
même qu'est ce qui t'a fait du
bien est ce que vous croyez à la mort
d'elvis non
elvis n'est pas mort donc il ya 20 % des
américains qui pensent comme vous mon
père est ce que vous croyez au sexe sans
amour
annoncé le pire qui puisse arriver à et
est ce que vous croyez à l'amour son
sexe oui je suis bien obligé
la communion des [__]
c'est la caisse
[Musique]
et maintenant j'accueille un ami
j'accueille celles qui comme disait mon
ami laurent ruquier dans on a tout
essayé va faire perdre la france cette
année à l'eurovision
jacquat et natasha st pier
le père de la morandais le futur roi
d'italie la future je suis désolé
gagnante de l'eurovision ne sais pas
vous porter la poisse et laurent baffie
notre ami à tous le grand auteur
dramatique laurent baffie
enfin que l'enfant de choeur voilà alors
vous avez 20 ans oui vous êtes né quant
au new brunswick dans l'est du canada
votre père d'origine italienne s'appelle
mario et directeurs de prisons des
téléconseillers tout petit nom ben j'ai
jamais eue part je me souviens que les
seules fois où j'avais passé comme en
parallèle la nuit dans des émeutes à la
prison pour essayer de régler tout ça
mais sinon il jamais rien arrivé qui m'a
qui m'est fait peur c'est que les
punitions quand tu te fais pas la
moyenne c'est le mythe art gallery
qu'une seule chine où ça a été tu sors
pas le week end est temps d'aller à la
mèche quand même non non attendez pas
une punition pas bon moi je pense pas
qu'il y ait de lachor qui ont même pas
non on peut pas changer de rôle
y'a qu'un truc qui colle savoir mon père
c'est que
babu g20
alors tu dis des bonnes un peu graveleux
jusque là
quelques rires voilà moi je prêche pour
sa paroisse marc d'accord
c'est que je te parle de quoi non ça ne
servait pas les filles comme ça quand ça
comique à l'esprit mal tourné
comportez comme michel rocard oui
vous étiez très précoce premier
spectacle à l'âge de 8 ans dans le camp
jeudi précoce et sur le plan
professionnel
premier album à l'âge de 14 ans et en
fait votre succès venu effectivement la
révélation est venue de notre dame de
paris jacques huret tient les 20 autres
noms de paris bah ouais j'avais pas
notre dame l'appareil ajouté moi je
enfin quoi des fautes à paroisse notre
dame de paris fait des 22 qu jeudi axa
qui m'a
je sais pas quand on lui met
à la place de belles figures graphiques
et à leurs
biens ensuite notre dame de paris à
londres harris voilà quoi pourquoi tous
ces québécois viennent en france baja
séparés par revoir michel drucker que
j'ai l'impression je me fais une
hypothèse personnelle parce que bon j'ai
pas la vérité absolue je crois que c'est
parce que comme il ya pas beaucoup de
francophones au canada on veut chanter
pour un plus large public on veut
enlever une carrière internationale et
le premier est le premier pas pour une
carrière internationale dans la même
langue que la nôtre c'est en france d'
accor abandonne la langue française à la
main pas pour l'instant non non non mon
cher un nom à nous lâcher un je suis là
devant la curée qu'est-ce qu'il faut tu
lâches aucun pas
l époque qui me faisait marrer
[Applaudissements]
non non non alors est ce comme ça bon
est ce que vous êtes venu en france
natasha st-pier pour trouver le grand
amour parce que mûrit mariage
[Applaudissements]
non mais si jamais c'est arrivé pourquoi
pas oui parce qu'en ce moment vous aviez
un jules en fait à montréal puis
maintenant c'est un peu bas c'est
terminé
il
s'était alors qu arrivera glace et c'est
fini la wii dont vous êtes open là ah
ouais bien voulu qu'on lance un appel
ben les i on a marié larusso 1 ah oui
elle c'est parce qu'il est plus facile
vous avez joué c'est bon
donc voilà je m'adresse aux millions de
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent un
jour qu'elle donne son profil souhaité
tu veux quoi oui
quelqu'un catholique croyant ça tombe
bien je suis dedans déjà
jurait mais c'est bon c'est mon frère
hugo
c'est le couple john mayer
alors on passe au blind test
et pour arbitrer et animer ce blind test
j'appelle monsieur philippe orgie
[Applaudissements]
m dos messieurs bonsoir là alors
on est prêt les séries cultes de la télé
numéro 1 didier
[Musique]
c
bien
allo
non
suivant
[Musique]
à
vous gagnez tout encore là les mecs font
des merveilles qu'est ce que vous faites
je l ai pris goût et on en a pris pour
vous exprès des séries télé j'allais
dire un gars
vous avez dirigé tellement tiennent le
d'élégance et il a tout gagné
non calmez vous
qu'il avait dit alors d'affilée suivante
m
c'est qu'ils étaient attendus
cécilia qu'a répondu me dit catherine
c'est tous les deux nous voilà leur
demeure allez
didier suivante
à l'étagé
[Musique]
non non
non ça marche pas pas suivant
[Musique]
bah
je suis
jamal
mannix
[Musique]
carency
je ne m'en nous
les bleus dieu aie aie aie vous avec eux
deux ils ont huit
jeux suivants
[Musique]
c
évidemment les inrockuptibles yamaha
vous étiez là
bien et maintenant vous connaissez la
loi de cette émission c'est très injuste
mais la vie juste celui qui va remporter
le super banco remportera le blind test
donc ça veut dire que même si vous avez
deux ou trois points pouvaient quand
même gagner à condition de lidl ont
concentré vous que vous trouviez le
suivant
attention vous êtes très didier
le
bret
m
et voilà vous avez gagné tout finalement
l'animatrice est emmerdé a trouvé
difficile presque remis et comme quoi la
vie est injuste
voilà des années qu'on n'a pas vu à la
télévision il a choisi tout le monde en
parle pour son retour médiatique tout le
monde va en parler voici anthony de loin
flo
donc
alors déconne
quand on est dans cette émission il ya
beaucoup de jolies filles et pas
beaucoup de beaux garçons je crois que
là ce soir c'est d'être servi d'abord il
ya anthony delon ensuite il ya jean marc
barr et après il ya hervé bourges
moi ya tellement gmail qui mendient
thierry sois gentil arrête de chanter
que dès qu'il ya un sampler je ferme ma
gueule d'ailleurs beaucoup plus
d'e-mails qui tandis qu'ericsson gens
qui arrêtent
donc finalement c'est bien alors anthony
delon j'ai 36 ans vous êtes né à los
angeles vous êtes le fils d'alain delon
bien sûr et de nathalie delon nathalie
delon vit aux états unis depuis depuis
une vingtaine d'années parce qu'elle
veut rentrer en france
alors je sais pas si les gens se
souviennent parce que les gens ne sont
pas connues tali de long c'était un
couple absolument extraordinaire votre
père et votre mère parce qu'il se
ressembler mais vraiment il avait
vraiment le même look ces navires sont
pris
hier une ressemblance parfaite et il
s'habiller pareil vous avez des photos
de cette époque pensait qu'ils étaient
frères et se voit là alors vos parents
divorcent quand vous avez quatre ans
c'est une fêlure pour vous parce qu'on
dit toujours que les divorces finalement
il vaut mieux des parents qui divorcent
que des parents qui s'engagent enfants
demande jamais la vie des enfants et
souvent quand on interviews des enfants
qui ont vieilli qui sauvent et les
adultes on s'aperçoit que ça a été très
douloureux pour eux c'était le cas pour
vous non parce que moi c'est arrivé très
jeune ils ont divorcé quand j'avais 4
ans donc en fait je me souviens
absolument pas d'avoir vécu avec l'un et
l'autre avance cette période dont je je
c'est pas une des choses qui m'a le plus
marqué je te dire lors des mineurs ce
qui s'appelait loulou et un leloup vous
la voyez toujours lui mais je la vois
toujours bien sûr vous avez quatre
enfants
et puis un parent qui est georges
labeaume qui est un agent historique du
cinéma français qui étaient en fait
votre vrai père non mon vrai père c'est
alain delon et suit
biologie bien sûr georges boum c'était
c'est toujours mon parrain donc si vous
voulez
mon parrain était là c'est vrai mon père
a été là aussi ça a été différent mais
mon père travailler beaucoup mon parrain
aussi mais il n'était plus disponible il
avait 20 ans de plus en général plus on
vit plus on est disponible pour les gens
qui sont proches de nous et c'est vrai
que j'ai passé beaucoup de temps avec
lui et qui m'a appris beaucoup de choses
alors bon alain delon on connaît les
problèmes que vous avez eue avec lui on
va pas y passer la soirée et simplement
lui il a déclaré je voulais les levées
dans la rigueur et la discipline
il m'a échappé il a refusé mon autorité
pour une vie plus facile vous vous êtes
d'accord avec ça non il veut la même
chose que moi il va même chose que tout
père si vous voulez c'est dire qu'à
partir du moment où vous fonder une
famille avec une femme vous avez un
enfant c'est l'osmose c'est le trinôme
parfait et est notre seul désir qui le
mien aujourd'hui puisque moi aussi je
super c'est de réussir ma vie de famille
et d'essayer de rester unie plus
longtemps possible et de
et d'y arriver donc c'est vrai que la
rupture pour lui a été difficile pour
nous pour tout le monde et c'est vrai
qu'il avait probablement une idée bien
précise de ce qu'ils avaient envie de
faire et il n'a pas pu le faire pour moi
parce que parce que la vie en a décidé
autrement et que et que normalement
quand deux parents divorcent l'enfant va
avec sa mère ouais ce qu'il a beaucoup
choqué votre père si vous souhaitez
réformer service militaire pour
insuffisance mentale et troubles
psychologiques chez lui l'avait fait la
guerre quand même indochine
dans ses tâches auxquelles vous fassiez
réformée du service militaire écoutez je
sais pas on en a jamais parlé mais je me
suis fait réformer ouais aujourd'hui
vous avez envie de régler les problèmes
un peu avec votre père vous dites je ne
voudrais pas enterrer mon père sur des
points de suspension en theresa pas le
faire marc est beaucoup mais je vous dit
je ne voudrais pas porter cela jusqu'à
la fin de mes jours ça me ferait
vraiment trop mal ça vous embête rai 2
finalement votre père disparaissent
avant que vous soyez réconcilier mon
père et moi bien sûr qu on s'est
réconciliés quand je je dis ça je dis qu
en fait il ya eu il ya eu il ya eu un
trou de 15 ans et on s'est perdus de vue
mon père ne me connais pas je le connais
pas et c'est vrai que le travail
aujourd'hui c'est pas de ceux de se
revoir et de faire parler parce que ça
c'est fait et parce que parce qu'on
s'aime mais c'est surtout de d'apprendre
à se connaître et de retrouver si vous
voulez cette union qui doit normalement
exister entre un père et un fils mais
sans se connaître ça prend du temps et
puis et puis l'huile et comme il aime
moi je suis comme je suis un chacun
votre caractère c'est ça donc c'est ça
c'est mal et j'aimerais j'aimerais
savoir qu'il est avant de l'enterrer ci
par le premier il quel jour là parce que
tu as la date de l'enterrement de son
père c'est incroyable la façon dont tu
parles oui mais tu sais pas ce que l'on
projette toujours et puis on vit un
accident peut vite arriver un feu de
brousse sur la ficelle peut y avoir un
accident votre vote officiel c'est à
dire qu'il va y avoir un accident bien
alors non il ya eu des histoires on se
souvient tous 185 votre père vous
interdit d'utiliser la marque à d pour
vendre vos blouson en cuir rose était en
train de faire une bonne affaire parce
que vous étiez je ne savais pas deuxième
des ventes derrière mac douglas
ça se passait bien j'ai pas en fait non
ça a été un peu déformés jeu la marque
ça plaît pas à des s'appelait anthony
delon donc mon père a pris pas
m'empêcher de le faire c'est plutôt si
vous voulez les gens avec qui il a il a
signé son contrat de licence qui ont
commencé à lui dire non mais attends de
la loterie ici fait ça etc etc vous
étiez associé avec un garçon qui était
directeur de boîtes de nick s'est fait
tirer dessus à l'époque qui s'appelait
tordjman ont été convoqués à la brigade
criminelle ce qui a fait aussi que ça
n'a pas aidé cette affaire de blues ont
rien à aider et non c'est sûr que compte
son associé se fait flinguer dans sa
voiture c'est pas ça
donc après on avait des impayés et puis
on a déposé le bilan
alors vous avez été interpellé deux ans
avant avant cette affaire donc en 83
dans une bmw volée est dans la boîte à
gants il y avait le pistolet voler un
policier lors de l'évasion de bruno
sulak qui est l ennemi public numéro un
j'ai piqué la mauvaise bagnols ouais
alors votre père est venu vous chercher
à la prison et vous n'avez pas été sympa
parce quand il est venu vous chercher la
plaisance vous avez dit il vient me
chercher pour se faire de la pub
ça lui a pas plu est fâché t'es pas
content non j'ai dit ça parce que
j'ai dit ça parce que j'ai vu dans la
photo qui était je pense en couverture
de deux matchs crew ailleurs un
photographe qui était son photographe
personnel à l'époque et qui était là
alors je me suis dit qu'est ce qu'il
fout là donc si vous voulez j'en ai
déduit que ouais quand vous êtes arrivé
dans la prise en main cellule on vous a
dit il y avait un type là un yougoslave
qui s'est pendu il ya quelques jours ce
s'est pendu il s'est pendu hier hier il
a cassé les vitres série s'est bien
goupillé
tu sais en prison en france on n'a pas
beaucoup de place ça faisait
des câlins et qui dégage on met l'autre
à la place sérieux là vous vous êtes dit
quand même la seule un peu loin quand
même non je me suis dit mais en plus en
quoi ils m'ont mis dans cette cellule
et puis surtout que les fenêtres étaient
cassées il faisait un froid de canard
on a tous à commencer vous avez fait une
fugue en fait au départ parce que vous
annoncez à votre père coup les deux
photographes c'est comme ça que ça a
commencé la dissension entre vous et guy
je vais t'envoyer en maison de
correction en pologne où tu veux c'est
la vie c'est vrai que
j'ai arrêté l'école je voulais plus
aller à l'école jeu la première année de
donc de première le premier jour la
première heure je m'assois en classe et
le type commence à parler je suis là je
me dis [__] j'en peux plus c'est fini
ouais faut que je me casse je dis
monsieur jouer est ce que je peux et aux
toilettes s'il vous plaît donc je suis
sorti à ce moment là je tombe sur
directeur qui s'appelait moschetti qui
était mon directeur à charlemagne parce
que j'étais aussi à charlemagne on a
essayé de me glisser là bas il médite de
l'eau qu'est ce que vous faites là je
suis monsieur j'ai mal aux couilles j'ai
demandé à sortir ça c'est véridique
immédiat seuil et vous ça va passer j'ai
ouvert un petit massage
j'avais 17 ans c'est normal elles sont
pleines il est parti et puis dès qu'il a
tourné à porte et j'ai dit c'est fini je
veux plus tu peux pas arrêter machin
pour faire quoi et puis je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai dix photographes ouais
photographe donc là à votre père vous
dis j'aurais pu dire n'importe bref je
vais soumettre en maison de correction
en pologne yougoslavie et là vous vous
retrouvez seul dans un appartement à
paris prêté par une danseuse du crazy
horse qui étaient partis effectivement
j'étais un peu lâchés dans la nature mam
est un bon vivant aux etats unis
mon père est moins c'était c'était
la brouille donc je me suis retrouvé
comme ça et puis j'habitais à droite à
gauche chez des copains etc jusqu'au
jour effectivement cette fille qui est
décroché un contrat de danseuse au crazy
au mexique nous a laissé son appartement
c'est un pad est il écrit
donc on était dans la cité va dans la
partie sud aubry qu'est ce qu'on va
mettre dans le frigo voilà qui nous
ramène dans le frigo donc effectivement
on fait des conneries ouais bon après
tout c'était un peu défoncé après non
mais bon bien après bien après un entre
20 et 30 ouais et après bien si on
apprécie tout autant vous allez non
grenache voix s'est tue songer à ses
pendants ouais tu peux non important que
celui du succès au cinéma c'est ça qui
est assez incompréhensible cerdan
chronique d'une mort annoncée le film de
de rossi vous aviez eu beaucoup de
succès les génies qui avait salué votre
talent rosie c'était bien c'était bien
d'ailleurs c'est le premier qu'on a vu
c'est le premier qui est sorti on a été
à cannes pour ça et effectivement ouais
j'avais bien démarré
mais ça a coïncidé avec justement le
moment où
où je me suis j'ai commencé à déconner
et derrière ça
j'avais plus envie de travailler je
faisais des conneries je me défoncer je
faisais voilà et puis deux ans après on
m'a dit mon agent à l'époque m'a dit tu
sais il faut que tu tournes parce qu'on
va t'oublier et j'ai fait la femme
fardée et la faisait tellement beau et
que c'était pas terrible et là j'étais
tellement bourré que ce n'était pas
terrible et à ce moment là je me suis
fait je me suis fait casser c'est normal
ouais vous êtes pris conscience quand et
comment qui fait d'arrêter la dope
j'ai pris conscience vingt neuf jours où
je
je me suis rendu compte que
j'étais devenu un
esclave vrai que la
doc m'avait pris ma liberté et ma
dignité alors aujourd'hui ça va bien
vous êtes avec sophie voilà une petite
fille qui s'appelle own où vous avez
fait une psychothérapie j'ai fait une
psychothérapie analytique way pendant
que dans en prenant deux ans puis
ensuite par moments j'ai retourné le
voir pour parler pour la série glee
ouais mais après ça devient commun ça
devient amie ça devient un membre de la
famille
je peux avoir envie de lui parler je
l'appelle je lui parle c'est bien parce
que c'est tout un c'est gratos m'attend
c'est un pote s'est jamais gratos
après c'est une signe c'est une
gymnastique quand on arrive quand on a
du mal à parler à ses amis ou même se
parler à soi on s'assoit puis c'est tout
un
intrus qui en route et puis paf c'est ça
aide quoi si c'était à refaire je le
referais tout pareil tous pareils même
l'ado tout j'ai ma revanche et les deux
longs pour y ait ce groupe comme ça un
peu du côté gangster un peu parce que
quand on lit les quand on lit la
biographie de votre père même s'il n'est
pas autorisée ce qui est sorti et est
pas complètement faux il aimait bien
jouer des révolvers tout ça ça vient
d'où ça par rapport aux belmondo qui
sont très rangée c'est vrai qu'en plus
c'est vrai que bordeaux
s'ajouter des gens qui se droguent pas
alors réponds bah ça vient d'où
et
lui il aime les armes il les a toujours
aimé je sais comme ça j moi j'aime
j'aime plus tellement c'est en fait je
crois que - j'ai été un petit peu et
c'est normal j'ai grandi avec le culte
d'un père était qui était acteur mais
qui était surtout
la star la star est la plus grande star
française
pendant 25 ans et puis qui était
toujours un flic - voyons un flic ou
voyou il a toujours un influent dans les
mains ou un zorro ou à j 3 euros mais
bon donc oui c'est ça que la mutation de
l'image du père voilà c'est normal oui
c'est le mimétisme toujours qui fait que
et c'est vrai qu'en plus j'avais
beaucoup de on sent quelque chose de
nouveau chez vous c'est vous avez de la
distance par rapport à votre personnage
à ce que vous êtes quoi et ça c'est
nouveau c'est vrai
j'ai de la distance parce que enfin si
d'abord je me suis jamais pris au
sérieux mais sinon nous non plus on t'a
jamais pu eux aussi
je me suis jamais pris au sérieux mais
j'avais une distance plutôt une distance
par rapport
en fait j'en avais ras le bol voilà j'en
avais ras le bol que les gens se fassent
une fausse idée parce que c'est vrai que
ça fait 15 ans que je me tais quand j je
me tais y sert que bon on me demande
toujours fait une interview fautif est
là et je le fais pas parce que parce que
j'avais pas envie et parce que bon pour
des raisons multiples et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui je me suis dit mais quand
je rencontre quelqu'un me dit mara mais
c'est drôle je pensais pas que c'était
comme ça je pensais que c'était un coup
enfin ils ne disent pas mais il le pense
ou peut-être prétentieux ou tt ce site
est fait cela 1 et
est en fait c'est pas ça et un moment
j'ai dit faux au four ou bien sûr que
j'ai beaucoup changé aussi c'est vrai
qu'à une époque où alors il ya une
époque où fermiers comme une huître
ouais c'est venu c'est venu de tout
temps une accumulation de choses c'est
venu de la femme fardée où je me suis
fait massacrer après c'est vrai que je
les prie je les prie je les prie en
pleine gueule et que j'ai pas gérer
vente
enfin j'avais 20 ans je dis à ce moment
là on n'est pas capable de prendre du
recul gt gt en plein dedans et et et
j'ai donné le bâton pour se faire battre
et puis si on m'a allumé c'est moi qui
ai déconné c'est moi tribu c'est moi qui
ai fait des conneries c'est moi qui me
suis défoncé c'est de ma faute mais si
tu veux ma première réaction est là et
et le rejet ah ouais vous moi je suis né
à sedan suivait tout bon allez vous
faire [__] sachets une azalée offert
non en écharde isme la série j'étais un
peu tendu mais là on échappe il ya hervé
bourges ce soir au quai d'ailleurs hervé
je vais lui demander de rentrer
maintenant
aller bien servi
mais sur le coup
eh bien allez regarder
modérer vos propos d'accord on est
content de voir comme ça faisait l'air
mieux vous avez en mieux dans votre peau
plus à l'aise
ce qui est terrible c'est que là les
excès que vous avez fait vous ont pas
marqué
bien alors anthony delon
vous avez eu des eaux vous avez eu des
bas on va faire l'interview ap ndar
le sait tout le monde le sait ne bouge
pas pendant le jingle
bien alors anthony delon ce que vous
préférez en vous mes mains
ce que vous détestez en vous mon père
noir être
l'anxiété
ce que vous préférez au cinéma
rêvé que vous haïssez au cinéma
la complaisance
le film de vous que vous préférez je te
qu'on le devienne de vous vous détestez
y en a beaucoup
lépine en choeur
le plus grand moment de votre vie
la naissance de ma fille vous
responsabilités de père de famille
maintenant c'est vrai que quand on a on
a un enfant on est on nous prend enfin
quelque part on se remet attaché on est
attaché à cet enfant bien sûr mais on
attaché à certaines choses on n'a plus
toutes les libertés cirque de demain je
peux pas prendre ma valise et partirez
disparaître
c'est bien vous trouvez ça bien c'est
bien mais c'est dur aussi ouais c'est
quelqu'un qui a besoin de vous
maintenant ouais ce qui vous plaît le
plus dans la vie il ya plein de choses
qui me plaisent
jamais de rentrer amis j'aime j'aime
aller au cinéma j'aime rire beaucoup
arrête tu vas trop loin déjà cette
fonction n'est pas clair je prends ma
fille dans mes bras j'ai
faim j'ai y tout falloir les joueurs de
la vie ce qui fait le plus chez nous
réveiller
les cons votre plus gros coup de fric le
crédit lyonnais raconte
j'ai jamais eu un gros coup de fric
votre plus grosse perte
ma plus grosse perte et ben ça sera
peut-être jeu de cons parce que jade
congé jouer dedans mais j'ai produit
aussi ce qui vous fait le plus rire dans
la vie
les trucs qu'on les gags leu leu leu leu
enfin le gepan ont de si reagan qui
descend de l'avion et qui se vautre qui
attrape son garde du corps qui tombent
avec lui enfin ce genre de truc quoi ça
me fait rire et le moi rire
les drames
tout ce que je vois à la télé
les plus belles histoires d'amour
abaissé celle là nancy reagan
sans déconner et à pécho d'anciens
copains et pas que nancy reagan
l'autre histoire d'amour la plus minable
bernadette
elle est très souhaitable
je sais plus julien d'aillé plein y en a
eu plein enfin tu sais le truc 5h du mat
tu rentres débourrer il rabroue dit
si vous êtes de plus sexy en vous
elle a dit les yeux l'autre derrière
dîner couilles
la faillite chapet je sais on a failli
échapper six intervenants plaisanciers 6
passes cash si pascal sellem s'était pas
cassé une côte et de moins sexy
la leaf est dit quelque chose
je t'avais gagner de 17 ans un public
ils font les couilles vraiment le monde
a changé 1 je sais pas moi les genoux
ouais voilà les genoux ouais ce que vous
préférez dans le sexe le plaisir de
l'autre c'est bien le dire ça à la télé
un
bon
c'est un bon jour mais c'est un bon plan
pour chiens
c'est l'opinion mais le plaisir de
l'autre c'est aussi mon plaisir et ma
femme va voir l'émission suit ses cours
n'est pas couché toi ce que vous
détestez dans le sexe ce que je déteste
cesser la pédophilie par exemple
[Musique]
jean deschamps
alex
chesnais et avec anthony delon bien sûr
j'accueille maintenant ari boulogne
ari boulogne bonsoir soit alors vous
êtes le fils de nicolas super star des
sixties ex mannequin égérie d'andy
warhol du velvet underground le mythique
groupe de lou reed et on regarde tout de
suite niko ça nous fera beaucoup dit
[Musique]
tout est
gelé
qui auront tous
[Musique]
ils rateront
je sais tout
australie temps
[Applaudissements]
lectra
oh
[Musique]
et à
ça y est
et
béchir
[Musique]
nico
mito et g
les stars du ghana 1 meur grande vous
aimez nico guillaume dustan suis hyper
fan de nico de warhol et toute cette
époque bien alors votre père c'est un
père qui ne vous a pas désigné pour fils
puisque alain delon a toujours refusé de
reconnaître cette paternité et vous
quand vous parlez de lui vous dites moi
je ne demande rien mais qu'il ne
m'accuse pas d'être un imposteur car
dans ce cas qu'il prouve que je ne suis
pas son fils et qu'il fasse un test
sanguin c'est bien votre déclaration
tout à fait pourquoi il l'a jamais fait
à votre avis
parce que il s'est tenu je mens rendu à
la mairie a été déboutée ça devait être
en 163 je pense après ma naissance et il
est pas de tester des années cette
époque là et depuis
j'ai entamé une procédure de
reconnaissance ans quand j'avais 18 ans
qui a été zappé quoi voilà enfin ce dont
on est sûr c'est que alain delon a fait
au moins une fois l'amour et votre main
oui ça il voulait dynastique ça il vous
l'a dit tout le monde le sait alors vous
êtes né donc de nico et peut-être
d'alain delon puisque jusqu'à
aujourd'hui ça n'a pas été prouvé en
1962 à la clinique du belvédère à
neuilly votre nom de naissance c'est
celui de votre mère c'est une perf des n
1 et votre prénom c'est aaron dit harry
puisque la veille votre mère avait vu au
cinéma exodus paix newman dans le rôle
de aron baynes canal vous pensez que
c'est peut-être pour effacer le le péché
des allemands qu'elle vous a appelé
comme ça donnait un nom hébraïque
peut-être
c'est une possibilité oui vous avez
parlé avec elle
non
alors plus tard on vous appellera ari
boulogne du nom de la mère d'alain delon
qui s'appelle et édith boulogne on va
voir comment on va voir pourquoi c'est
une histoire incroyable
vous racontez ça beaucoup d'autres
choses dans un livre qui s'appelle
l'amour n'oublie jamais qui est édité
chez pauvert
mise en vente 40000 exemplaires en douce
pourquoi peur des avocats
non je ne savais pas même je savais pas
combien d'exemplaires était de cire et
donc 48 mais ça a été mis en vente en
douce en cadets mais j'essaie je sais
moi puisque j'étais même pas sorti
alors on va en parler interview vérité
dans la bouche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien dans carrie boulogne
c'est effectivement vous ressembler
beaucoup alain delon vous le dis dans la
vie comme ça on ne le dit oui souvent
les gens vous disent dans la rue dans la
rue ça m'arrive c'est plus les
chauffeurs de taxi ouais voilà ils vous
disent comme ça je m'attaque si vous
n'êtes pas le fils d'alain delon vous y
en a même un qui était là on à dos avec
lui des moyens jour et à berlin ça m'est
arrivé ouais parce que parfois ça
m'emmerde un con con qu'on parle de ça
donc j'ai dit non non vous vous trompez
tir de personnes
et puis à berlin quand je tournais nikon
il ya un chauffeur de taxi et vous êtes
le fils est là dedans j'ai dit mais bien
sûr - cyril ce qui était sympathique
l'humain les avocats d'alain delon quand
on leur parle de vous disent que c'est
des coïncidences morphologique
c'est un peu facile
le plus incroyable dans votre histoire
si vous avez eu deux vies parallèles
aussi dissemblables que possible d'un
côté avec nico votre mère permissivité
absolue chez les hippies de new york
diby ça vous est déjà pris goût à
l'arrêt à l'héroïne auprès de auprès de
cette bande de gens auprès de votre mère
et de l'autre côté les règles
moralisante de bourg la reine puisque
vous avez été recueillis d'une certaine
façon par la mère et le beau père
d'alain delon et vous dormiez comme vous
étiez petit dans le lit où avaient été
conçus alain delon il avait dormi avant
vous et et finalement vous aviez un pied
dans la banlieue comme ça et et un autre
dans des endroits et plus dans les
endroits les plus bizarres de la planète
non oui jusqu'à l'âge où il a fallu
ma mère ne pouvoir plus occupé de moi de
par son travail il fallait qu'elle
assure au jour le jour sa sas habitants
ce quoi ce qu'était payer 5 dollars la
journée le concert donc elle pouvait
plus s'occuper de moi l'appeler ma mère
ma grand mère pardon qui est venu me
chercher donc à new york alors
évidemment le summum de votre enfance
c'est donc d'abord effectivement d'avoir
vécu ces deux vies parallèles et surtout
quand votre mère nico du velvet
underground débarqué à bourg-la-reine
parce que d'un seul coup elle débarquer
en banlieue et vous vous convier à
inversement quand vous alliez à new york
et que vous alliez à la factory de
warhol et que vous parliez à ces gens-là
de dorothée la tortue que vous aviez
dans le jardin de bourg la ddt vous avez
une enfance complètement schizophrénique
absolument alors ce livre bon et
consacré d'abord avant tout je dirai au
culte de votre mère
c'est un culte qui s'est forgée à la
factory c'est pas là que tout a commencé
gatien aussi alors elle était la
superstar encore nous disait à l'époque
supervise la wii c'était là la superstar
dans les warhol et vous quand vous
alliez à la factory très jeune j'étais
un peu la mascotte de la factory
et donc vouloir servir un petit peu des
fois de couverture quand il fait des
descentes de bonnet joué parce que
j'étais très très jusqu'à loupé par tous
temps vous les aidiez quand j'avais des
flics qui débarque et la factory est
alors en même temps je les fais des
films avec eux vous avez journée dormi
j'ai joué dans chelsea games est un film
de paul maurice est un exploitant 84
voilà
alors un jour un espion envoyé par là
par la famille bolen donc la famille
d'alain delon vous voilà factory finir
des verts après en fin de soirée tout
petit que l'âge vous aviez j'avais
entre quatre et cinq ans voilà il
finissait des verts il avaler des
pilules qui était dans le sac de sa mère
d'ailleurs à 80 m vous avez une hépatite
et la mère d'alain delon donc edit
boulogne est venu vous récupérez à new
york c'est cela et vous à embarquer dans
ce pavillon à bourg la reine elle édite
boulogne la mère de l'un d'eux l'on est
persuadé vous êtes le fils de son fils
tout à fait un la direction du zloty
elle l'a écrit oui elle a écrit vous
reproduisez une lettre dans good book a
alors elle édite boulogne la mère de
l'un d'eux l'on vit avec monsieur
boulogne qui est son second mari en fait
c'était son second mari qui était un
type assez bizarre parce qu'il avait
beaucoup bu ils étaient murées sur
l'émail moi que je les quand j'ai quand
je l'aï connu il avait arrêté de boire
quelqu'un effectivement qui qui ne
disait pas grand chose c'est quelqu'un
de très cartésien de très simple mais
j'avais beaucoup d'affection pour lui
j'ai toujours beaucoup d'affection pour
lui
c'est quelqu'un qui m'a permis de
découvrir la pêche par exemple des
choses simples comment faire une épice
sûrs non c'est quelqu'un de mairie alors
en fait ce monsieur boulogne n'était pas
le père d'un enfant le père de
l'indolence et fabien 2000 qui est
partie du domicile conjugal quand alain
delon avec quatre ans refaire sa vie pas
très loin d'ailleurs dans la même
banlieue et vous l'avez vu vous il n'a
pas refait sa vie il n'a pas il a pas
bougé de la maison qu'ils habitaient
disait ma grand mère qui a fait sa vie
avec monsieur vous donne mais vous
l'avez vu vous ce fabien delon gelé vue
attendant son bus way we quand j'étais
quand j'étais jeune quand et et quand ce
fabien delon est parti alain delon a été
confiée à des familles d'accueil et on
peut lire sur le site internet alain
delon en ce moment là qu'il a été confié
à une famille d'accueil à fresnes enfin
ceci explique aussi beaucoup de choses à
dire qu'alain delon se retrouve en train
de jouer dans la cour d'une prison
puisque sa mère ne s'occupant pas de lui
il avait été confié à une famille
d'accueil à fresnes alors faut dire que
question antécédents vous avez une
lourde hérédité puisque l'autre grand
père sur le le père de nico votre grand
père maternel
tokyo man
il se fait beaucoup à ma mère et de ma
mère est née opiomane we hope you man
vivait dans un house boat sébastien
fleury n'a gardons au début des années
30 amis de gandhi et donc votre mère est
née de par là même vous dites opiomane
ce qui explique oui elle est née avec
une double pneumonie ouais donc l été
oui ça explique sur l'addiction à
l'héroïne oui à ces jeunes quoi
est-ce qu'on peut pas dire normalement
comme resplendissant autres
bien sûr oui c'est une femme on est
cerné truite pas les revenus à ça fait
quoi ça ne détruit pas
la preuve j'ai toujours là moi aussi
j'en prends
est-ce qu'on peut pas dire harry
finalement que comme la mère d'alain
delon c'était pas bien occupé de son
fils puisqu'il avait été mis dans des
familles d'accueil on vient d'en parler
à fresnes est ce qu'on veut à dire
qu'elle vous a couvé d'une certaine
façon vous pour s'amender pour se faire
pardonner d'une certaine façon oui je
pense oui ouais
sans aucun doute parce que c'était elle
mélangeait les noms des tendances à la
piale ouais
donc alors c'est une vie un sens c'est
parce que quand vous êtes à
bourg-la-reine vivait avec la présence
de ce père qui ne vous reconnais pas à
photographier et à la télévision il en
photo il hanté à vue dites dans votre
livre la télé semble n'avoir été
inventée que pour passer des films
d'alain delon et quand il dit sa mère
donc votre grand mère le voilà terrell
il a des valeurs sous les yeux en face
c'est une espèce de promiscuité
médiatique incroyable oui et un jour il
yal'affaire markovits donc c'est que
c'est l'assassinât du garde du corps
d'alain delon une affaire sera beaucoup
parlé à l'époque et à ce moment là vos
grands-parents donc monsieur boulogne et
dit boulogne par peur peut-être d'un
enlèvement vous mettre en pension sans
même prévenir votre mère et vous passez
et c'est terrible ouais passé neuf ans à
saint louis à montfort l'amaury mais
les années de votre vie vous ont été
gelés oui c'est
c'est pas de chance quand c'est tout
quel âge vous aviez
j'avais 6 ans
dans une institution aux catholiques
assez rigoriste faut bien le dire où les
chutes chez les châtiments corporels
étaient de mise
mon père
nous commente l'église doit balayer
régulièrement devant sa porte seulement
un châtiment corporel
était dur
donc vous voyez gentil requin se faire
cravacher jusqu'au centre argentin parce
que c'est un troisième qui les grands
perversion quelques uns sont soulevés
par les oreilles donc le directeur qui
arrivait par derrière parce que les
portes communiquer entre chaque classe
sans faire de bruit ou fument pas sur
les deux oreilles
en même temps on est à trois reprises
ses non dits en dur dur vraiment alors
vous ne voyez plus votre mère et en plus
vous entendez du mal d'elle c'est à dire
que votre douleur est traversée d'un
hatem du style mauvaise mère droguée
salle drogués ça y
est elles vous cherche oui et on vous
dit pas qu'elle vous cherchent non et
ses lettres on les remet par un ton mais
on hermès et après lecture
pas mes grands-parents maintenant
excusez moi j'ai ouvert cette lettre par
mégarde
alors à l'époque c'est lé premier boulot
vous commencé à bosser acheteurs voit la
première fille aussi pour leurs
expériences sexuelles il a vous êtes
adoptée par les boulogne c'est à dire
que vous abandonnez votre nom de berri
genk et le nom de nico qui s'appelle
nico il s'appelait christ américaine
exactement et donc vous dites cette
adoption c'est le fruit d'un lavage de
cerveau grèce a commencé très tôt c'est
à dire dans cette école à la prière et
huit fois par jour
l'overdose
le catéchisme
et puis surtout ces petits vieux que
j'étais entouré de vieux quoi pour la
reine dieu de la génération de mes
grands-parents quoi ouais donc qu'ils
doivent avoir il ya là plus à gênés et
tu as envie à 95 ans
quand vous revoyez votre mère en 79
s'est dit pas que c'est beau parce que
ce serait un mot malheureux mais disons
que vous êtes défense et tous les deux
et d'un seul coup vous avez une espèce
de deux communautés ensemble vous avez
quelque chose en commun une drôle de
complicité parce que c'est vrai que des
fois votre mère vous allez chercher de
l'ado pour elle donc j'avais une espèce
j'ai quelque chose en commun ils
trouvent que c'est l'hérault mais c'est
quand même quelque chose en commun c'est
sur une deux trois générations quoi
alors à la même époque vous rencontrer
serge gainsbourg oui à l'elysée matignon
qui vit par contre et n'aime pas du tout
ça ouais et cierges vous présente
anthony de l'oim vous allez vous avez 18
anthony delon à 16 ans vous sorti de la
boîte vous sortez l'elysée matignon
vous mettez sur un banc avenue matignon
évidemment et il vous parler et lui vous
dit qu'il est venu quelquefois jouer
dans le sous-sol du pavillon de bourg la
reine et pendant que j'étais en pension
à saint-louis donc à montfort l'amaury
et ils vous racontent l'emporté donc dit
il venait le mercredi voilà ma grand
mère ils vous racontent qu'ils
empruntent et votre voiture bleue à
pédales voilà c'est pas très bien qui
c'était mais c'est au fils de charcutier
en disait sa voix on lui disait sa fin
c'étaient les jouets du fils de
charcutier
dont vous étiez en plus long pont secret
quoi puisque l'enfant secrets ses
enfants du placard
alors vous dites à anthony delon il y
avait une gentillesse indéniable de son
côté mais quelque chose ne fonctionnait
pas entre vous parce que quand c'est en
un courant qui ne passait pas ouais
c'est parce que lui colle quand ils vous
raconter ses malheurs pour vous ça vous
semble et quand même un truc pas très
grave parce qu'il était riche quand même
ils débarquaient dans toutes les boîtes
de nuit les bouteilles à son nom elle
craque et du doigt ouais
voilà sur il était c'était un luxe ouais
même ça ça c'est à dire toutes ces
dérives et même sociale son malheur vous
semblez quand même un luxe par rapport à
la vie que que vous viviez oui mais
voilà alors après il faut lire le
bouquin c'est un bouquin très étonnant
très bien écrit vous au nez comme ça
entre new york et paris pendant de
nombreuses années la votre grand père
meurt enfin votre grand père monsieur
boulogne ont bien sûr boulade l'autre
grand père adoptif honneur vous
rencontrer alain delon lors de
l'héritage enfin chez le notaire et ils
parlent de vous en disant lui il dit
qu'est-ce qu'il aura lui qu'est ce
qu'ils ont à me voyez moi j'ai rien
et vous retombez sur lui un jour quand
vous allez embrasser votre grand-mère à
bourg-la-reine avant de rejoindre nico
on tournait vous dire au revoir votre
grand mère il là vous dites c'est la
rencontre la plus intense que j'ai
jamais eue avec lui et de longs très
bizarrement se comporte avec vous comme
si vous êtes toujours connu à ce moment
là oui mais c'est non
il est tellement bon comédien est bonne
at her que il a
d'abord manger c'est tartelettes
on se retourne en pro b pour pas qu'on
le voit manger
est bon mais ramener à paris en tapant
sur les pompes étaient mon pote toi tu
es mon pote mais je vais te dire un truc
n'est pas mon fils ne sera jamais mon
fils
de là jusqu'à paris tap à média tu n'as
pas mes yeux tu n'as pas mes cheveux oui
et pourtant j'ai couché qu'une seule
fois avec ta mère n'était pas mon fils
sera jamais mon fils est là dessus je
lui dis mais si moi je dois ton avis
mais ce que je dois aussi stipulé qu'il
n'y ait aucun
approchement fait entre nous et là il me
dit ah non surtout pas tuer ce terrain
la tension
là c'était avant qu'il me déposait la
cession ni trop passive ouais alors et
vous dépose au métro pas signer avant de
vous déposez il vous dit ton père ses
deux pôles et on de pollen voilà un mot
extrêmement mystérieuse mais ça son truc
c'est un moment incroyable
donc c'est ton père ses deux pôles et on
vous dit qui ces deux polluants c'est
napoléon c'est tartempion est ce qu'il
n'a pas dit ça pour se [__] de ma
gueule et je dire d'un coup et alors là
votre oncle bernard a émis l'hypothèse
d'une part tous c'est à dire que votre
père ne serait pas sûr d'être votre père
parce que vous auriez été conçu à
l'occasion d'une partouze sa cc c'est un
délire total quoi c
c'est mon oncle bernard n'était pas là
pour voir moi elle est n'est pas la
chandelle alors alain delon vous laisse
au métro pas si vous ne me pose même pas
de boire un verre non même pas ouais non
moi je pensais qu'on irait boire un café
ensemble ou entretenant un homme dans un
rade
voulait pur vu non plus jamais
je laisse ici je les revenus à
l'enterrement de ma grand mère alors
votre meilleur meurt en 88 à ibis à
votre grand-mère en 95 vous avez revu
donc à l'occasion de l'enterrement de
votre grand-mère j'imagine rien de
particulier ce jour là un très froids
comme ça a dit ce temps et tout ça et
aujourd'hui vous vivez avec véronique
oui et vous avez un enfant oui qui
s'appelle charles et sept enfants harry
est allé le reconnaître le jour même
[Musique]
charles la vie continue
harry si alain delon était en face de
vous maintenant vous lui diriez quoi
j'me fais tu as peur alain c'est la
phrase de pomerol dans le film voilà ce
serait spécial si celle que vous n'êtes
pas osé lui dire mais trop passifs
non
plus du riz au journal et ses services
dire aujourd'hui ouais tu me fais pas je
je le dis et raymond gants si c'était
encore pote permis aux dix neuf
commodités au 19e siècle
parce que c'est une manie inadmissible
ce qu'il a fait
on rallume
est ce que vous croyez que vous
arriverez à lui pardonner à votre père
bon là c'est super oh là là et sur bien
sûr moi je suis pas je suis pas le
parrain dit qu'a donnée le dieu
vengeurs quoi foudroyant
et serait lui ferait du bien plus à lui
d'être pardonné par là il a les moyens
via mon pardon
merci
chjama mesdames messieurs nous arrivons
maintenant au moment du blind test
attention attention spéciale fis ce soir
c'est normal c'était une émission
spéciale fis guidiez
et pour animer et arbitrer le blind test
j'appelle moi je suis enfui pour quartz
hu
espace
c'est dominique segall nom vient à la
barre alors pas pour juste un an je suis
venu avec de deux jeunes acolytes qui
vont m'aider à comptabiliser les points
magnifiques rico qui est de ce côté ci
qui va jouer avec mépris qu ici ici sean
chat qui pêche égal et si on te demande
étoiles les plus belles filles tu les
veux tu n'es verrai où ou temps je me
sais au brésil bon donc on va jouer le
brésil ici voilà brésil quant aux
l'italie puisque l'italie elles sont
belles aussi daniel voilà attention
daniel il faut gagner ce soir aussi
daniel sait pas tout d'avoir été
champion du monde de handball
faut gagner au blind test maintenant
c'est pas tout ça bien donc il ya filles
dans le pit moi ce que je vous demande
c'est l'interprète à ses garde du coeur
didier
tieger
c'est l'équipe c'est l'équipe
[Musique]
voilà très bien voilà vous êtes fort les
mecs attention deux vitesses
[Musique]
complet
comme quoi l'arbitrage vidéo a du bon
bah oui parce que voyez comme quoi on
peut faire des énormes erreurs parce que
moi je pensais que c est
pourquoi je t'ai déchets que ce jour
charge aux antilles challenge alors que
l'italie à brésil faut offrir une rose à
wigan alors s'il vous plaît chaîne
s'appelle chain et regardant pousser je
peux sauver le garçon oui parce que tu
peux faire un cadeau ouvrira cette
touchette regarde bien un pétale bruno
witek à eric thomas ça m'arrive de me
poggia les enfants continuent chanson
numéro
[Musique]
coutadeur
et choisir
alors attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien connaître au cul
m
parce que tout
c'est salut les copains monde en somme
alors brésil italie trois
mandatures de venir habiter un petit peu
en france soir
venir en france et plus en face votre
culture française aux etats-unis benamar
mexico je peux le faire je vais me
donner un double stricte commençait pas
mélanger les points
attention attention
[Musique]
oui
l'interprète avec lui figé mais ces
rageux
ralentis faut qu'un bureau
qui sait
réfutant bien pas m
aller chez moi ou fabricants mais doit
faire mon petit bouquet
je veux pas celle que nous croyez
je suis
bon je vais vous le dire si ces annonces
film le public on vous écoute c'est m6
qui a dit philippe lavil là venez avec
les filles
[Musique]
quand il faut quand il faut
paru
la bravo bravo vous appelez comment
dorment à nancy vous avez déshabiller
attendez vous connaissez la règle du jeu
bravoure tu les corps applaudi voilà
très bien alors attention continue
didier six
d'égaliser cette vallée de la paix
ce cadre
je
y figurent déjà dans qu'italie 4 brésil
[Applaudissements]
c'est mauvais
chanson numéro 7
[Musique]
ouais
je sais que des brevets
attention a jugé jeudi au public je
connais toute l'oeuvre de d'ailleurs je
sais que j'ai lu c'est 106e cm on sait
simplement jeudi au public si vous
répondez à non vous laisse y répondre
les invités ci répondra vous répondez
didier 8
[Musique]
la batterie est neuve
non
le membre à toutes les filles
depuis
la
vidéo du canton l'année suivante en
vidéo sinon ce contrôle s'est
effectivement félix gray rédigé
barbelivien
après tout
ces données quand même pas la musique
c'est faux
toutes les filles
[Musique]
ouais
alors certes
bruno solo
de quoi y est
on y retourne
avec simone
tous
sans jouer
mais ça y aller
là
ils réussissent brésil 2 est bon pied
[Musique]
eddy mitchell
martin reviendra au
jeu
d'abord bravo mais comment vous
connaissez tous et à martin mais c'est
bien bravo moi ça se voit c'est bien
martin pendant que vous êtes vous voulez
pas fait appel aux pirates
isabelle roseraie contente bon continue
didier
alors c'est comme ça
aujourd'hui une fois qu'ils ont reconnu
tarek parce que c'est insupportable
c'est gentil italie ben si c'est le
brésil remonte avec trois points grâce à
notre ami bruno solo qui a reconnu il
était une fois je vous félicite bruno
solo
parce que j'avais pas beaucoup de
disques a devrait durer tout est jeune
ça va non il est déjà question est très
bien chez
moi donc de la gifle didier
[Musique]
ces pages il y en a
qu'est ce qui se branche mans cyndi
lauper
ben on attendait les macchabées
pour moi c'est sûr
en échange de tous ces changements pour
moi c'est ok je vais déjà pas mon coup
mais on l'attendait cadeau cadeaux
d'aschbach jade olivier cadiot et
apparaît parce que là et là c'est
vraiment dur là
non comment il s'appelle déjà c'est la
presse
ces données scotch cheval public la
jeune fille
[Applaudissements]
non non
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
on a
je suis désolé c'est une colline va bien
entendu
aujourd'hui c'est halloween collins
internet les girls like you pay
demoiselle vous venez venez ici venez
ici italie 6 brésil 4
bravo vous appelez comment oui donnez
vous à l'aise véronique m'a bien alors
là maintenant nous arrivons à la fin de
ce blind test et celui ou celle qui va
trouver bah finalement c'est le choc
armengaud faire que quelques étés les
résultats auparavant celui ou celle qui
trouvent ça gagne de blind test c'est
injuste la vie est injuste
et gagne véronique et marche est partie
attention c'est le super banco didier
[Musique]
le pen normand madonna bal public
consiste à 13 heures
ban public et la nina non mais qu'est ce
t'as dit
m
grâce à l'analyse continue
gagner
sans qu'ils s'arrêtent des cultes dans
une éclipse adp gagne c'est
extraordinaire on a fait gagner le
brésil il ya donc le brésil gagne en
tension
le et voilà
c'était tout n'aura pas
[Musique]
non
je ne sais pas
[Musique]
savoir quand même
m
[Musique]
il est là
me baby mois
oui
c'est qui
news corp
c'est curieux
m
on a
on
sam
[Musique]
no
savoir quand même
m
[Musique]
il déménage
du baby boom
oui
tu
dieu
quand
thank you
on a
on
non
[Musique]
no
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible